Don't let paperwork stress you out this tax season. Take a deep breath because Record Express is here to shred your worries away. Record Express offers secure and eco-friendly shredding solutions for businesses and individuals of all sizes. Choose from our convenient plant-based shredding services, where your documents are securely destroyed at our state-of-the-art facility. Or opt for our mobile shredding service. And we'll bring the destruction directly to you. Visit recordexpress.ca for a free quote today.
在这个报税季，别让文书工作让你感到压力。深呼吸，因为Record Express在这里帮你消除烦恼。Record Express为各种规模的企业和个人提供安全且环保的碎纸解决方案。您可以选择我们便捷的工厂碎纸服务，您的文件将在我们最先进的设施中被安全销毁；或者选择我们的移动碎纸服务，我们将直接上门为您销毁文件。立即访问recordexpress.ca获取免费报价。
That's recordxpress.ca. Store, scan, Shred Canadian. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children
网址是recordxpress.ca。存储、扫描、加拿大碎纸。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。今天的剧集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，
and won't be suitable for all listeners. The small, sleepy village of Lepange-sur-Vallone lies in northeastern France towards the German border. In 1980, it was home to less than 1,000 inhabitants, many of whom came from families that lived in the area for generations. The quaint rural hamlet was typical of the region. Orange-tiled houses and evergreen forests dotted the grassy hillsides, with the Vallone River snaking through the valley. The main road offered little besides a school, news agency and a small selection of cafes and bakeries A majority of the townsfolk were employed at one of the local factories Suffice to say, not much happened in La Panche It was an ordinary village filled with ordinary working class people
并不适合所有听众。安静的勒庞日叙瓦隆村位于法国东北部，靠近德国边境。1980年，这里居住着不到1000名居民，其中许多人来自在该地区生活了几代人的家庭。这个古朴的乡村小村庄是该地区的典型代表。橙色瓦片的房屋和常青森林点缀着长满草的山坡，瓦隆河蜿蜒穿过山谷。主干道上除了学校、新闻社和几家咖啡馆及面包店外，几乎没有其他设施。大多数镇民都在当地的一家工厂工作。可以说，勒庞日没发生过什么大事。它只是一个充满普通工薪阶层的普通村庄。
In the early 1980s, phone lines were installed in the area for the first time. In July 1981, newlyweds Jean-Marie and Christine Villemin took advantage of this development and had a line installed to their newly built home. It had been an exciting time for the young couple, who were both aged in their early twenties. Christine had recently given birth to their first child, a son named Gregory. Jean-Marie secured a coveted position as foreman in a car upholstery factory, bringing a new level of financial stability to the young family.
20世纪80年代初，该地区首次安装了电话线。1981年7月，新婚夫妇让-马里·维尔曼和克里斯汀·维尔曼利用这一发展，在他们新建的家中安装了一条电话线。对于这对二十出头的年轻夫妇来说，那是一段令人兴奋的时光。克里斯汀最近生下了他们的第一个孩子，一个名叫格雷戈里的儿子。让-马里在一家汽车内饰工厂获得了一个令人垂涎的领班职位，为这个年轻的家庭带来了新的经济稳定。
They'd purchased a plot of land on the outskirts of La Panche and built a comfortable yet modest chalet-style home with plans to extend as their family grew. The future looked bright. One night, shortly after they'd had their new phone installed, it rang. Christine answered. All she could hear on the other line was heavy breathing. Then the line went dead. It happened again, and again. One silent anonymous call after the next placed at random times for several days. One night, Jean-Marie picked up. This time, he could hear a record playing.
他们在勒庞日的郊区买了一块地，盖了一栋舒适但朴素的小木屋风格的房子，并计划随着家庭的壮大进行扩建。未来看起来很光明。一天晚上，在他们安装新电话后不久，电话响了。克里斯汀接了电话。她在电话那头只能听到沉重的呼吸声。然后电话就断了。这种情况发生了一次又一次。在接下来的几天里，一次又一次的沉默匿名电话在随机的时间打来。一天晚上，让-马里接了电话。这一次，他能听到播放唱片的声音。
It was the song We Are Thirsty by Belgian singer Gran Jojo. A giggling female voice sang along out of time to the upbeat song, which told the story of a member of the Foreign Legion's quest to find a beer. Still, the caller said nothing. A few nights later, the phone rang again. Another song played, but still no conversation. The hang-up calls continued for several months. More heavy breathing and long silences. Then, in November, mysterious caller for months. The couple lived in the neighbouring village of Aumonze, located 11 kilometres east of La Panche.
那是比利时歌手格兰·乔乔演唱的歌曲《我们口渴了》。一个咯咯笑的女声跟着这首欢快的歌曲跑调地唱着，歌词讲述了一名外籍军团士兵寻找啤酒的故事。尽管如此，打电话的人什么也没说。几天后，电话又响了。另一首歌在播放，但仍然没有对话。挂断电话的情况持续了几个月。更多沉重的呼吸声和长时间的沉默。然后，在11月，神秘的打电话者已经持续了几个月。这对夫妇住在勒庞日以东11公里的邻村奥蒙泽。
They'd raised their six children there while taking turns working shifts at the local textile factory. while taking turns working shifts at the local textile factory. Most of their children had married and fled the nest, except for their youngest son, who was only 12 years old. The others all still lived nearby and would get together on Sundays to catch up over a meal. The calls to Albert and Monique varied in length and content. Sometimes the caller would say nothing, other times they'd rant for up to half an hour. Often the calls were studded with sneers, vile language and threats. A majority of the time the caller was a man with a hoarse, muffled voice who was obviously trying to disguise his natural speech.
他们在那里抚养了六个孩子，同时轮流在当地的纺织厂上夜班。他们的大多数孩子都已经结婚并离家独立，除了他们最小的儿子，他才12岁。其他人仍然住在附近，每周日都会聚在一起吃顿饭叙叙旧。打给阿尔伯特和莫妮克的电话在时长和内容上各不相同。有时打电话的人什么也不说，有时他们会咆哮长达半小时。电话中经常夹杂着嘲讽、恶毒的语言和威胁。大多数时候，打电话的人是一个声音沙哑、低沉的男人，显然是在试图掩盖他自然的说话方式。
But the calls were occasionally made by a woman, or possibly a man speaking in a high-pitched voice. The caller eventually earned themselves the nickname of The Crow after the 1943 French film of the same name. In the movie, a mysterious rider terrorises a small town with anonymous letters that expose everyone's dark secrets. Although the identity of the Villemans Crow remained unknown, one thing was certain. This wasn't some random stranger. The Crow had intimate knowledge of the Villemarne family that only an insider could be privy to. They knew where each family member lived, who they were married to, where they worked, and how they spent their days. They knew whenever something new happened within the family and of the changing dynamics and conflicts within. Whoever the crow was,
但电话偶尔也会由一个女人打来，或者可能是一个用尖细嗓音说话的男人。打电话的人最终为自己赢得了“乌鸦”的绰号，取自1943年的同名法国电影。在电影中，一名神秘的骑手用匿名信恐吓一个小镇，揭露了每个人的黑暗秘密。虽然维尔曼家族的“乌鸦”身份仍然未知，但有一点是肯定的。这绝不是什么随机的陌生人。乌鸦对维尔曼家族有着只有内部人士才能了解的亲密了解。他们知道每个家庭成员住在哪里，他们和谁结婚，在哪里工作，以及他们如何度过每一天。他们知道家庭中发生的任何新事情，以及内部不断变化的动态和冲突。无论乌鸦是谁，
they were watching the Villemarne family closely. Their motivation wasn't clear, but there were a couple of elements they were particularly fixated on. Albert and Monique's eldest child, Jackie, had been born out of wedlock. He wasn't Albert's biological child at all, but the result of a brief fling Monique had just before their marriage. Albert had married Monique to save her the shame and stigma of being an unwed mother. Regardless, Albert never accepted Jackie as his son, and he was mostly raised by his maternal grandparents. It had been a sore spot within the family, especially for Jackie, who only learned the truth about his background at the age of 17.
他们都在密切监视着维尔曼家族。他们的动机尚不清楚，但有几个要素是他们特别关注的。阿尔伯特和莫妮克的长子杰基是婚外所生。他根本不是阿尔伯特的亲生孩子，而是莫妮克在婚前短暂风流的结果。阿尔伯特娶了莫妮克是为了让她免受未婚母亲的羞耻和污名。无论如何，阿尔伯特从未接受杰基作为他的儿子，他主要是由外祖父母抚养长大的。这一直是家庭中的一个痛处，尤其是对杰基来说，他在17岁时才得知自己身世的真相。
The Crow continually honed in on this, referring to, quote, the bastard and insinuating there could be more bastard children among them. The Crow appeared sympathetic towards Jackie and often came to his defence. Michel Villemarne was the second eldest son of the clan. He was illiterate, poorly spoken, and had low self-esteem. The Crow complained that Michelle was treated badly. In contrast, the Crow had a particular disdain for Jean-Marie. His recent promotion to foreman was a sore spot for some family members,
“乌鸦”不断地抓住这一点，引用“私生子”一词，并暗示他们中间可能还有更多的私生子。乌鸦似乎对杰基表示同情，并经常为他辩护。米歇尔·维尔曼是家族中的次子。他不识字，说话粗鲁，自尊心很低。乌鸦抱怨米歇尔受到了不好的对待。相比之下，乌鸦对让-马里有着特别的蔑视。他最近被提升为领班，这让一些家庭成员感到不满，
who envied that Jean-Marie had managed to rise above their working class ranks. that Jean-Marie had managed to rise above their working class ranks. The Crow spitefully referred to Jean-Marie as boss. Their dislike for Jean-Marie was borderline obsessive. The Crow knew how proud Albert and Monique were of their middle son, and he continuously encouraged them to cut all ties with Jean-Marie and his family. The Crow seemed determined to drive a wedge between members of the Villemain family and turn them against one another. And it worked.
他们嫉妒让-马里设法超越了他们的工薪阶层地位。乌鸦恶毒地称让-马里为“老板”。他们对让-马里的厌恶近乎痴迷。乌鸦知道阿尔伯特和莫妮克对他们的二儿子有多么自豪，他不断鼓励他们切断与让-马里及其家人的所有联系。乌鸦似乎决心在维尔曼家族成员之间打入楔子，让他们反目成仇。而且它奏效了。
Conflicts began flaring up among the siblings, parents, and extended relatives as allegations arose as to who among them was behind the Crow. The extended Vilmang clan had no shortage of dark family secrets, and the Crow wasn't afraid to use this information against them. Albert's father had hanged himself when Albert was only 12 years old. The Crow constantly encouraged Albert to do the same. Christine Villemin was home alone with baby Gregory when the phone rang on November 22 1981. Jean-Marie was working the night shift. It was the first time Christine
随着关于谁是乌鸦幕后黑手的指控出现，兄弟姐妹、父母和远房亲戚之间的冲突开始爆发。庞大的维尔曼家族不乏黑暗的家庭秘密，而乌鸦并不害怕利用这些信息来对付他们。阿尔伯特的父亲在阿尔伯特只有12岁时上吊自杀了。乌鸦不断鼓励阿尔伯特也这样做。1981年11月22日，克里斯汀·维尔曼独自在家带着婴儿格雷戈里时，电话响了。让-马里正在上夜班。这是克里斯汀第一次
heard the hoarse voice of the crow for herself. The mystery caller began unleashing a barrage of insults. Christine quickly hung up. This enraged the crow. He immediately called back and the insults worsened. He threatened violence, making it clear he knew exactly where Christine lived and what her movements were like. Christine asked the caller what she ever did to deserve this harassment. The crow responded, It's not you. It's your old man. Later that night, Christine heard a rattling noise at her front door. She went to investigate, only to discover that a latch on the door had been broken
亲耳听到乌鸦那沙哑的声音。神秘的打电话者开始发出一连串的侮辱。克里斯汀迅速挂断了电话。这激怒了乌鸦。他立即回拨，侮辱变本加厉。他威胁要施加暴力，明确表示他确切地知道克里斯汀住在哪里，她的行踪如何。克里斯汀问打电话的人她到底做了什么才招致这种骚扰。乌鸦回答说：“不是你，是你那个老头子。”那天晚上晚些时候，克里斯汀听到前门有嘎嘎作响的声音。她去查看，结果发现门上的插销被弄坏了，
and a window pane had been smashed. Christine bundled Gregory up and rushed to her next-door neighbour's house. After that, she became consumed by fear. Jean-Marie bought a.22 calibre rifle for himself and a pistol for Christine. He reinforced all of the windows of their home with shutters. He reinforced all of the windows of their home with shutters. Christine refused to stay alone in the house at night. Whenever Jean-Marie worked nights, she took Gregory to stay at her mother's. Meanwhile, the calls continued at Albert and Monique's house. The crow told them, I broke down the boss's door. His wife was scared.
窗玻璃也被砸碎了。克里斯汀抱起格雷戈里，冲向隔壁邻居的家。从那以后，她被恐惧所吞噬。让-马里为自己买了一支.22口径的步枪，并为克里斯汀买了一把手枪。他用百叶窗加固了家里所有的窗户。克里斯汀拒绝晚上独自待在家里。每当让-马里上夜班时，她就带着格雷戈里去她母亲家住。与此同时，阿尔伯特和莫妮克家的电话还在继续。乌鸦告诉他们：“我砸了老板的门。他老婆吓坏了。”
The Villemans weren't the type of people to involve law enforcement. Like many others in the region, they were old school and somewhat stubborn. They believed that conflicts should be sorted out between those involved. They believed that conflicts should be sorted out between those involved. Instead, Albert and Monique started recording the time, date and content of each phone call in a notebook. Afraid they too would be physically targeted, Albert installed car mirrors throughout their property. The Crow immediately told Albert that he knew about the mirrors. Had a family member told them, or had the Crow seen it for themselves?
维尔曼一家不是那种会报警的人。像该地区的许多其他人一样，他们很守旧，而且有些固执。他们认为冲突应该在当事人之间解决。相反，阿尔伯特和莫妮克开始在笔记本上记录每个电话的时间、日期和内容。由于担心自己也会成为身体攻击的目标，阿尔伯特在他们的房产周围安装了汽车后视镜。乌鸦立即告诉阿尔伯特，他知道镜子的事。是家庭成员告诉他们的，还是乌鸦自己看到的？
The surveillance was constant. One July day in 1982, Monique and Albert went for a stroll with their son Gilbert and his wife. Upon their return home, the phone rang. It was the all-too-familiar voice of the crow. Did you have a nice walk? he asked. In September 1982, Gilbert was at work when a woman called to let him know that his mother had been in a terrible accident. Gilbert rushed to his parents' house, only to find that Monique was completely unharmed and oblivious to any such call. There had been no accident. As soon as Gilbert left, Albert and Monique's phone rang. It was the crow, laughing about how stupid and
监视是持续不断的。1982年7月的一天，莫妮克和阿尔伯特带着他们的儿子吉尔伯特和儿媳去散步。他们回到家时，电话响了。那是乌鸦那再熟悉不过的声音。“你们散步愉快吗？”他问道。1982年9月，吉尔伯特正在工作时，一个女人打来电话，告诉他他的母亲出了严重事故。吉尔伯特冲到父母家，却发现莫妮克完全没有受伤，也不知道有这样的电话。根本没有发生什么事故。吉尔伯特刚离开，阿尔伯特和莫妮克的电话就响了。是乌鸦，嘲笑着吉尔伯特有多么愚蠢和
gullible Gilbert had been. On Tuesday November 30 1982, the phone rang incessantly at Albert and Monique's house. The crow racked up a grand total of 27 calls. The couple had finally reached their limit. They reported the caller to the local police and an investigation was launched. Determining the identity of the Crow was no easy feat. Phone records at the time noted the amount of calls made from a landline, but didn't specify which local numbers had been dialed. There was heightened activity on the phone accounts of several members of the Villemant family during peak times when the crow was active. This in and of itself wasn't necessarily suspicious. Each call from the crow provoked other calls
轻信。1982年11月30日星期二，阿尔伯特和莫妮克家的电话响个不停。乌鸦总共打了27个电话。这对夫妇终于达到了极限。他们向当地警方报告了打电话的人，调查随即展开。确定乌鸦的身份并非易事。当时的电话记录记录了从固定电话拨出的电话数量，但没有具体说明拨打了哪些本地号码。在乌鸦活跃的高峰时段，维尔曼家族几名成员的电话账户活动频繁。这本身并不一定可疑。乌鸦打来的每一个电话都会引发其他电话，
within the family, making it an ongoing chain reaction. Despite the different dynamics within the family, no one stood out as a clear suspect. The crow had insinuated the identity of various individuals, but this was likely an intentional way to deflect from the truth. Given that the crow was sympathetic towards Jackie, there were suspicions that Jackie himself was behind the calls. Jackie's wife, Lillian, had an incredibly strange relationship with the Villemans, so it made sense that she could have been the female accomplice. She had a relationship with the Villemans, so it made sense that she could have been the female accomplice. She had also been at Albert's home when he installed the mirrors.
在家庭内部形成了一种持续的连锁反应。尽管家庭内部的动态各不相同，但没有人作为明确的嫌疑人脱颖而出。乌鸦暗示了不同个人的身份，但这很可能是一种故意转移真相的方法。鉴于乌鸦对杰基表示同情，有人怀疑杰基本人就是电话背后的主谋。杰基的妻子莉莲与维尔曼一家的关系非常奇怪，所以她可能是女性同伙是有道理的。当阿尔伯特安装镜子时，她也在场。
Lillian's parents disliked the Villemans and some wondered whether Lillian was feeding them information. Could Lillian be the mastermind behind the crow and her father the one executing the calls? Tensions among the family escalated. Sunday get-togethers became hostile and unpleasant. Albert and Jean-Marie were convinced that Jackie was the crow. When confronted with this accusation, Jackie strongly denied it. He was so offended that he stopped seeing his family altogether. The police thought the crow could possibly be identified through a process of elimination. The next time the crow rang, the recipient was advised to call the person they suspected to be responsible. Were they standing by the phone? Could they notice any similarities in the voice? On Monday December 13 1982, the Crow called Albert and Monique to announce,
莉莲的父母不喜欢维尔曼一家，有些人怀疑莉莲是否在向他们提供信息。莉莲会是乌鸦背后的主谋，而她的父亲是执行电话的人吗？家庭内部的紧张局势升级。周日的聚会变得充满敌意和不愉快。阿尔伯特和让-马里确信杰基就是乌鸦。当面对这一指控时，杰基强烈否认。他感到非常受辱，以至于完全不再见他的家人。警方认为乌鸦可能通过排除法被识别出来。下一次乌鸦打电话时，建议接听者给他们怀疑负责的人打电话。他们当时在电话旁吗？他们能注意到声音有什么相似之处吗？1982年12月13日星期一，乌鸦打电话给阿尔伯特和莫妮克宣布，
I'm going to La Ponge to hurt Christine. The next morning, Jean-Marie discovered that the tyres on his car had been slashed. When Albert found out, his paranoia grew. He grabbed his rifle and began scouring his property. The crow called shortly after, laughing at Albert for his actions, which he seemed to have observed. The relentless calls continued into 1983, with the Crow targeting Albert and Monique a total of 17 times in one day. The female Crow began to appear more and more frequently.
“我要去勒庞日伤害克里斯汀。”第二天早上，让-马里发现他的车胎被划破了。当阿尔伯特发现时，他的偏执加剧了。他抓起步枪，开始搜查他的房产。乌鸦不久后打来电话，嘲笑阿尔伯特的行为，他似乎一直在观察。无情的电话一直持续到1983年，乌鸦在一天内总共17次针对阿尔伯特和莫妮克。女性乌鸦开始越来越频繁地出现。
She could often be heard in the background of the calls, and sometimes made the calls herself. On one occasion, she called a funeral home and declared that Albert Villemarne was dead. Staff showed up at the Villemarne's home prepared to collect a corpse. By this point, all four of the adult Villemain sons, Jackie, Michel, Jean-Marie and Gilbert, had received calls from the Crow As had their wives Others had witnessed these calls take place Michel was the only one who had been alone every time he was contacted by the crow. He claimed the crow had threatened,
她经常可以在电话背景中听到，有时甚至亲自打电话。有一次，她打电话给一家殡仪馆，声称阿尔伯特·维尔曼已经死了。工作人员出现在维尔曼家，准备收尸。到目前为止，所有四个成年的维尔曼儿子——杰基、米歇尔、让-马里和吉尔伯特——都接到了乌鸦的电话，他们的妻子也接到了。其他人目睹了这些电话的发生。米歇尔是唯一一个每次接到乌鸦电话时都独自一人的人。他声称乌鸦威胁说：
I know what time you leave for work, when your wife comes home, and when your children are alone. When Monique answered the calls, the crow mostly remained silent. In early 1983, she began encouraging him to talk, hoping to diminish some of his power. That's when the death threat started. Referring to Jean-Marie, the crow told Monique,
“我知道你什么时候去上班，你妻子什么时候回家，以及你的孩子什么时候独自一人。”当莫妮克接听电话时，乌鸦大多保持沉默。1983年初，她开始鼓励他说话，希望能削弱他的一些权力。就在那时，死亡威胁开始了。提到让-马里，乌鸦告诉莫妮克，
I'm going to kill him. I already scared his wife. I will do it again soon. Christine often unplugged her phone to avoid the harassment. The crow seemed to be aware of this. One night he called Monique and said, I watch her. I know she is alone at home. She can unplug her phone, but maybe I'll come this evening. Monique tried not to act perturbed. She insinuated they'd discover the crow's identity eventually. He responded, You assholes, you will never get me. Besides, I can't be touched. One day, the female crow called Christine at work, pretending that her husband had been in an accident. On another occasion, she called the fire department, claiming that Albert Villemarne had hanged himself.
“我要杀了他。我已经吓坏了他老婆。我很快会再做一次。”克里斯汀经常拔掉电话线以避免骚扰。乌鸦似乎意识到了这一点。一天晚上，他打电话给莫妮克说：“我看着她。我知道她一个人在家。她可以拔掉电话，但也许我今晚会去。”莫妮克尽量表现得不慌乱。她暗示他们最终会发现乌鸦的身份。他回答说：“你们这些混蛋，你们永远抓不到我。再说，我碰不得。”有一天，女性乌鸦打电话给克里斯汀的工作单位，假装她的丈夫出了事故。另一次，她打电话给消防部门，声称阿尔伯特·维尔曼上吊自杀了。
claiming that Albert Villemin had hanged himself. By Friday March 4 1983, the Crow had been harassing the Villemin family for over a year and a half. That day, Jean-Marie noticed an envelope tucked into the window shutters on his house. It was addressed to him. Inside was a single-page note written in block capital letters. I will kill the Villemain family. Three weeks went by before the Crow made contact again. This time, Jean-Marie managed to record the call as the Crow made cryptic revelations about there being, quote, another bastard in the family.
声称阿尔伯特·维尔曼已经上吊自杀了。到1983年3月4日星期五，这个“乌鸦”已经骚扰维尔曼一家一年半多了。那天，让-马里注意到他家窗户的百叶窗里塞着一个信封。信是写给他的。里面是一张用大写字母书写的单页纸条。我要杀了维尔曼一家。三周过去了，“乌鸦”才再次联系。这一次，让-马里设法录下了通话，当时“乌鸦”做出了一些神秘的披露，称家族里还有，引用原话，“另一个杂种”。
The clearer of the two voices belongs to Jean-Marie Villemin. The softer, distorted voice is the crow.... A few weeks later, a woman called Jean-Marie's work, asking to speak with him. By the time Jean-Marie answered, the crow was on the line, a female's voice audible in the background. a female's voice audible in the background. Although the Crow often talked to others about his hatred for Jean-Marie, he rarely spoke to Jean-Marie himself. Jean-Marie tried to act cool and casual. If he didn't react, maybe he could undermine the harasser.
两个声音中较清晰的一个属于让-马里·维尔曼。那个较柔和、扭曲的声音是“乌鸦”……几周后，一名女子打电话到让-马里工作的地方，要求与他通话。当让-马里接听时，“乌鸦”已经在电话那头了，背景中可以听到一个女人的声音。虽然“乌鸦”经常向别人谈论他对让-马里的仇恨，但他很少直接与让-马里交谈。让-马里试图表现得冷静和随意。如果他不做出反应，也许他就能挫败这个骚扰者。
They spoke on the phone for 40 minutes. The Crow told Jean-Marie that his brother Jackie wasn't the only illegitimate child amongst the siblings. He claimed that Monique was keeping a secret from the whole family. She had allegedly continued a relationship with Jackie's father after she married Albert and he'd impregnated her for a second time. Jean-Marie tried to shrug things off, asking for more information as proof. His composure seemed to aggravate the crow. The crow threatened to burn down Jean-Marie's house. He responded, Go ahead, I'll just build another one. threatened to burn down Jean-Marie's house. He responded,
他们在电话里聊了40分钟。“乌鸦”告诉让-马里，他的兄弟杰基并不是兄弟姐妹中唯一的私生子。他声称莫妮克对整个家庭隐瞒了一个秘密。据称，她在嫁给阿尔伯特后继续与杰基的父亲保持关系，并且第二次怀上了他的孩子。让-马里试图不以为意，要求提供更多信息作为证据。他的镇定似乎激怒了“乌鸦”。“乌鸦”威胁要烧掉让-马里的房子。他回答说：“去吧，我大不了再盖一栋。”
Go ahead, I'll just build another one. The Crow then threatened to rape Christine. Jean-Marie continued to remain calm, saying, I don't care. The Crow described Jean-Marie and Christine's house, making it clear he knew exactly what the interior looked like and what kind of furniture they had. I'll go after your kid, he said. Don't leave him lying around. I'm watching him with binoculars. If I find him outside, I'll take him away. Jean-Marie could no longer maintain his composure. His son Gregory was his life. He snapped back,
“去吧，我大不了再盖一栋。”随后，“乌鸦”威胁要强奸克里斯汀。让-马里继续保持冷静，说：“我不在乎。”“乌鸦”描述了让-马里和克里斯汀的房子，很明显他清楚地知道内部的样子以及他们有什么样的家具。“我会去找你的孩子，”他说。“别让他一个人待着。我正用望远镜盯着他。如果我发现他在外面，我就把他带走。”让-马里再也无法保持冷静了。他的儿子格雷戈里就是他的命。他反驳道：
''You bastard. If you touch my kid, you're a dead man.'' The police had agreed to set up wiretaps on Albert and Monique's telephone. Monique made the mistake of telling some family members about this. The crow found out, and the call stopped. On Wednesday April 27 1983, an envelope arrived in Albert and Monique's letterbox. Written in the same block letters as the one sent to their son, the letter read, If you want me to stop, let me offer you a solution. Don't visit the boss anymore. Cut him off entirely. If you don't, I will execute the threats I made to the boss and his little family.
“你这个杂种。如果你敢动我的孩子，你就死定了。”警方同意在阿尔伯特和莫妮克的电话上安装窃听器。莫妮克犯了一个错误，把这件事告诉了一些家庭成员。“乌鸦”发现了，通话就停止了。1983年4月27日星期三，阿尔伯特和莫妮克的信箱里收到一个信封。信上的字体与寄给他们儿子的那封信一样，都是大写字母，信中写道：“如果你想让我停手，让我给你一个解决方案。别再去看那个老板了。彻底断绝与他的联系。如果你不这样做，我将执行我对老板和他那小家庭的威胁。”
Jackie and his family have been through enough. It's the boss's turn to be considered a bastard. He will console himself with his money. You choose. Life or death. Three weeks later, Albert was at work when one of his colleagues told him there was a woman on the phone asking to speak with him. Albert picked up the receiver. The voice of the male crow said,
杰基和他的家人已经受够了。现在轮到那个老板被视为杂种了。他会用他的钱来安慰自己。你选吧。生还是死。三周后，阿尔伯特正在工作，一位同事告诉他有个女人在电话里找他。阿尔伯特接起听筒。那个男性“乌鸦”的声音说：
You will hang yourself. The next day, another letter arrived at Albert and Monique's home. This one was much longer than the others and written in scrawling cursive. I see nothing has changed, it began. The boss is still coming. It went on to defend Jackie before addressing Albert directly. You old man, you look very ill to me. I'm quitting and you'll never know who pissed you off for two years. You may not hang yourself but I don't care because my revenge has been made. I hate you so much that I will spit on your grave the day you die. This is my last letter and you will hear no more from me.
“你会上吊自杀的。”第二天，另一封信寄到了阿尔伯特和莫妮克的家中。这封信比其他的长得多，是用潦草的连体字写的。“我看到什么都没变，”信的开头写道。“老板还在来。”信中继续为杰基辩护，然后直接对阿尔伯特说：“你这个老头，在我看来你病得很重。我要退出了，你永远不会知道是谁让你烦了两年。你可能不会上吊，但我不在乎，因为我的复仇已经完成了。我恨你恨到在你死的那天我会往你的坟墓上吐口水。这是我最后一封信，你不会再收到我的消息了。”
You will wonder who I was, but you will never find out. Goodbye, my dear idiots. Over a year went by with no further word from the mysterious crow. Life returned to normal. Christine Villemarne worked as a seamstress at a local clothing factory. Tuesday October 16 1984 was a typical workday for the 24-year-old. She knocked off at around 4.53pm and jumped into her car, a black Renault 5. Four-year-old Gregory was just around the corner at his nanny's house. Christine picked him up, but she couldn't stay to chat as she had a load of clothes that needed ironing.
“你会想知道我是谁，但你永远不会发现。再见，我亲爱的白痴们。”一年多过去了，神秘的“乌鸦”再也没有消息。生活恢复了正常。克里斯汀·维尔曼在当地一家服装厂当裁缝。1984年10月16日星期二，对于这位24岁的年轻人来说，这是典型的工作日。她在下午4点53分左右下班，跳进她的车，一辆黑色的雷诺5。四岁的格雷戈里就在拐角处的保姆家。克里斯汀接了他，但她不能留下来聊天，因为她有一堆衣服需要熨烫。
The mother and son arrived home just after five o'clock. Gregory wanted to play outside. There was a pile of gravel in the driveway that he liked to use as a racetrack for his toy cars. Although it was a relatively warm autumn day, Gregory was recovering from a cold, so Christine made him put on a woolen hat first. She then went to a room towards the back of their house where the shutters were drawn. She turned the radio up and got stuck into the ironing. By the time Christine finished, it was about 5.30. She went outside to tell Gregory it was time to come indoors.
母子俩在五点多一点回到家。格雷戈里想在外面玩。车道上有一堆碎石，他喜欢把它当作玩具车的赛道。虽然这是一个相对温暖的秋日，但格雷戈里刚从感冒中恢复过来，所以克里斯汀先让他戴上了一顶羊毛帽。然后她去了房子后面的一间房间，那里的百叶窗拉着。她调大收音机，开始熨烫衣服。当克里斯汀完成时，大约是5点30分。她走到外面告诉格雷戈里该进屋了。
His toy car sat on the gravel pile, but Gregory himself was nowhere to be seen. Christine called out her son's name. There was no response. She started searching around the yard, but couldn't find Gregory anywhere. She went back inside in case Gregory was hiding from her, but the house was empty. She approached one of her neighbours who was sweeping outside. He hadn't seen Gregory either, nor had his wife who was sewing inside. Another neighbour was tending to their cows in the nearby pasture, but they hadn't noticed the young boy.
他的玩具车放在碎石堆上，但格雷戈里本人却不见踪影。克里斯汀喊着儿子的名字。没有回应。她开始在院子里四处寻找，但到处都找不到格雷戈里。她回到屋里，以为格雷戈里在跟她玩躲猫猫，但屋里空无一人。她走近一位正在外面扫地的邻居。他也没见过格雷戈里，他那在屋里缝纫的妻子也没见过。另一位邻居正在附近的牧场照看奶牛，但他们也没注意到这个小男孩。
Panic washed over Christine. She got into her reno and sped back to her nanny's house on the off chance Gregory had wandered back there. He hadn't. Christine drove to the home of one of Gregory's friends in case he'd gone there to play. But Gregory wasn't anywhere to be seen. Meanwhile, at 5.32pm, the phone rang at the house of Jean-Marie's brother, Michel. He lived next door to their parents in Ormondsey and was watching TV at the time. Michel immediately recognised the hoarse voice on the other line.
恐慌席卷了克里斯汀。她上了她的雷诺车，飞速赶回保姆家，心想格雷戈里可能又溜回那里了。他没有。克里斯汀开车去了格雷戈里的一个朋友家，看看他是不是去那里玩了。但格雷戈里哪里都不见踪影。与此同时，下午5点32分，让-马里的兄弟米歇尔家里的电话响了。他住在奥蒙塞父母家的隔壁，当时正在看电视。米歇尔立刻认出了电话那头嘶哑的声音。
This time it sounded muffled, as though the caller had covered the mouthpiece with a handkerchief. that sounded muffled as though the caller had covered the mouthpiece with a handkerchief. I'm calling you because there is no answer next door, the crow said. I took revenge on the boss and kidnapped his son. I strangled him and threw him in the vallone. His mother is looking for him, but she won't find him. My revenge is done. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Monique and Albert Villemin were tracked down nearby and informed of the call from the crow. Monique was horrified.
这一次听起来很闷，好像打电话的人用手帕捂住了听筒。他说：“我打电话给你是因为隔壁没人接，”乌鸦说。“我向老板复仇了，绑架了他的儿子。我勒死了他，把他扔进了瓦隆河。他妈妈正在找他，但她找不到他。我的复仇完成了。”Casefile很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。莫妮克和阿尔伯特·维尔曼在附近被找到，并被告知了“乌鸦”的电话。莫妮克感到惊恐万分。
The crow had made many threats over the years, but this one was unusually specific. Monique immediately called her daughter-in-law Christine to warn her. There was no answer. Christine was still outside, desperately searching for Gregory. Instead, Monique called her son Jean-Marie at work, followed by the local police. Jean-Marie raced home, went inside, and grabbed his gun. For a long time, he'd been convinced that Lillian's parents, Roger and Paulette Jaquel, were behind the crow. It made sense given the crow's peculiar concern for Jackie. Jean-Marie rushed over to the Jaquelels' home, certain he would find his son there. When he arrived, he saw two vehicles which he thought were police cars parked outside.
多年来，“乌鸦”发出了许多威胁，但这一次特别具体。莫妮克立即打电话给她的儿媳克里斯汀警告她。没有人接听。克里斯汀还在外面，绝望地寻找格雷戈里。相反，莫妮克打电话给在工作的儿子让-马里，随后又报了警。让-马里冲回家，进屋拿起了枪。长期以来，他一直确信莉莲的父母，罗杰和波莱特·雅克尔，是“乌鸦”背后的主使。考虑到“乌鸦”对杰基的特殊关心，这说得通。让-马里冲到雅克尔家，确信他会在那里找到他的儿子。当他到达时，他看到两辆他认为是警车的车停在外面。
He backed away. A search party quickly gathered. Citizens and police scoured the woods surrounding Lepange on the lookout for the four-year-old with long curly brown hair. He was dressed in a blue jacket, dark green trousers and a blue woolen cap. The hours ticked by, the light giving way to night. Still, there was no sign of Gregory. night. Still, there was no sign of Gregory. Six kilometres downstream from La Pange was the small village of Doselle. Firefighters there searched the Vallone River. At 9.15pm, they came to a small bend. Just ten metres past a small footbridge, they noticed something bobbing in the water against a weir. They got closer. It was Gregory Villemarne. A firefighter jumped in the river to retrieve Gregory's lifeless body. The young boy was obviously deceased. He was fully clothed,
他退了回来。搜救队迅速集结。市民和警察搜查了勒庞日周围的树林，寻找那个留着长卷棕色头发的四岁男孩。他穿着一件蓝色夹克、深绿色裤子和一顶蓝色羊毛帽。时间一分一秒地过去，天色渐暗。仍然没有格雷戈里的踪迹。在勒庞日下游六公里处是多泽勒小村庄。那里的消防员搜查了瓦隆河。晚上9点15分，他们来到一个小弯道。在离一座小人行桥仅十米远的地方，他们注意到水里有什么东西在堰边漂浮。他们走近一看。是格雷戈里·维尔曼。一名消防员跳进河里打捞格雷戈里毫无生气的尸体。这个小男孩显然已经死亡。他穿着整齐，
his wrists and ankles bound together with thin pieces of robe. His woolen hat had been pulled over his face and was loosely secured around his neck with the same type of robe. The firefighters removed Gregory's hat. There were no signs of violence. On the contrary, they were struck by how serene and unblemished he looked, as though he was in a peaceful sleep. Gregory hadn't been strangled like the crow said. In fact, the forensic pathologist who conducted his autopsy couldn't find any signs that a struggle had taken place at all. There were no bruises on Gregory's body, nor had the rope left any marks on his skin. His clothes were clean and there was no evidence of sexual assault.
他的手腕和脚踝被细绳子绑在一起。他的羊毛帽被拉到脸上，并用同样类型的绳子松松地系在他的脖子上。消防员摘下了格雷戈里的帽子。没有暴力迹象。相反，他们惊讶地发现他看起来如此宁静，没有任何瑕疵，就像在安详地睡觉一样。格雷戈里并没有像“乌鸦”说的那样被勒死。事实上，进行尸检的法医病理学家根本找不到任何发生过挣扎的迹象。格雷戈里的尸体上没有淤青，绳子也没有在他的皮肤上留下任何痕迹。他的衣服很干净，也没有性侵犯的证据。
A small amount of water found in Gregory's distended lungs and foam in the corners of his mouth indicated his cause of death to be drowning. Due to the cold temperature of the water, forensic pathologists concluded the young boy would have stopped breathing within moments of being submerged. There were a multitude of locations between La Pange and Doselle where the killer could have dumped Gregory's body into the river. The day after Gregory was killed, tyre tracks and the imprints of a woman's shoe had been found in the riverbank at a clearing in the village of Desimone. This was 2.3 kilometres from the Villemans' home and several kilometres upstream from Doselle. Police obtained a mannequin with similar proportions to the four-year-old. They visited the location in Desimon and threw it into the water. By the time the mannequin reached Doselle, it had passed through various bends, branches, rocks, and other obstacles.
格雷戈里肿胀的肺部发现少量水，嘴角有泡沫，表明他的死因是溺水。由于水温寒冷，法医病理学家得出结论，小男孩在被淹没后片刻内就会停止呼吸。在勒庞日和多泽勒之间有许多地方，凶手可以将格雷戈里的尸体扔进河里。格雷戈里被杀后的第二天，在德西蒙村的一片空地上，在河岸上发现了轮胎痕迹和女人的鞋印。这距离维尔曼家2.3公里，距离多泽勒上游几公里。警方获得了一个与四岁男孩比例相似的人体模型。他们访问了德西蒙的地点，并把它扔进水里。当人体模型到达多泽勒时，它已经经过了各种弯道、树枝、岩石和其他障碍物。
Given that Gregory's clothing hadn't been torn and his body showed no scratches or bruises, it was deemed impossible that he'd travelled that far downstream. The mannequin was thrown from various other locations, including behind a fire station right near the centre of Doselle. The station was mere metres from the location where Gregory had been found. Police concluded that this was most likely the place from which his small body had been thrown. Gregory's parents, Jean-Marie and Christine Villemin, were inconsolable. Little Gregory had been the light of their lives. He was a delightful, intelligent child, full of happiness and energy. He loved to dance, especially to the music of Michael Jackson. Cheeky, with a contagious laugh, Gregory got a great thrill out of playing pranks on his parents.
鉴于格雷戈里的衣服没有被撕破，尸体上也没有划痕或淤青，人们认为他不可能被冲到那么远的地方。人体模型是从其他几个地点扔下的，包括多泽勒中心附近的一个消防站后面。该站距离发现格雷戈里的地点仅几米之遥。警方得出结论，这很可能是他的小尸体被扔下的地方。格雷戈里的父母，让-马里和克里斯汀·维尔曼，悲痛欲绝。小格雷戈里曾是他们生命的阳光。他是一个可爱、聪明的孩子，充满快乐和活力。他喜欢跳舞，尤其是迈克尔·杰克逊的音乐。格雷戈里顽皮，笑声具有感染力，他从捉弄父母中获得了极大的快感。
But for all his mischief, he was equally tender and affectionate. He was particularly fond of his stuffed monkey, Kiki, who he took with him everywhere. Gregory loved hugs and kisses and would sneak into his parents' bed on weekends to enjoy the extra long cuddles. Complicating de Villemain's crippling grief was the unbelievable reality that someone within their own family could do something so cruel. Who could hate them enough to take the life of their only child? Jean-Marie cast suspicion on his brother's in-laws, Roger and Paulette Jaquel, and the couple were taken into custody. They both had airtight alibis and were promptly ruled out.
但尽管他很淘气，他同样温柔且富有爱心。他特别喜欢他的毛绒猴子奇奇，他走到哪里都带着它。格雷戈里喜欢拥抱和亲吻，周末会溜进父母的床上享受超长的拥抱。让维尔曼一家悲痛欲绝的还有这样一个令人难以置信的现实：他们家族内部竟然有人能做出如此残忍的事情。谁会恨他们到夺走他们唯一孩子的生命？让-马里怀疑他兄弟的姻亲，罗杰和波莱特·雅克尔，这对夫妇被拘留了。他们都有不在场证明，并很快被排除了嫌疑。
As Jean-Marie and Christine struggled to comprehend what was happening, an envelope arrived in their mailbox the day after Gregory's death. It was addressed to Jean-Marie using swirling cursive. Inside was a short, anonymous letter. It read, short, anonymous letter. It read, I hope that you die of grief, boss. Your money can't give you back your son. Here's my revenge, you bastard. The envelope was postmarked 5.15pm on Tuesday October 16, the day Gregory was killed.
当让-马里和克里斯汀努力理解正在发生的事情时，格雷戈里死后的第二天，他们的信箱里收到一个信封。信封上用潦草的连体字写着让-马里的名字。里面是一封简短的匿名信。信上写着：“我希望你悲痛而死，老板。你的钱换不回你的儿子。这是我的复仇，你这个杂种。”信封上的邮戳是10月16日星期二下午5点15分，也就是格雷戈里被杀的那天。
It had been sent from the La Pange post office, which was 1.3 kilometres north of the Villemans' home. Postal workers said the last mail collection occurred around 5.20pm, but the mailbox could have been emptied any time between 1.55 and 5.20pm that day. Given that Gregory was abducted sometime between 5.05 and 5.30pm, this presented a few possibilities. 1. The killer had sent the letter before speeding to the Villemans' house to snatch Gregory. 2. The killer already had Gregory with them when they posted the letter. Or 3. They hadn't acted alone. It seemed unlikely that the killer would have sent the letter prior to the kidnapping.
它是从勒庞日邮局寄出的，该邮局位于维尔曼家以北1.3公里处。邮政工作人员说，最后一次邮件收集发生在下午5点20分左右，但信箱可能在当天下午1点55分到5点20分之间的任何时间被清空。鉴于格雷戈里是在下午5点05分到5点30分之间被绑架的，这提出了几种可能性。1. 凶手在飞奔到维尔曼家抢走格雷戈里之前寄出了信。2. 凶手在寄信时已经带走了格雷戈里。或者3. 他们不是单独行动的。凶手在绑架前寄出这封信似乎不太可能。
Had they done so, they would have had to have full confidence that the abduction was going ahead. How could they be sure Gregory would be playing outside? What if the opportunity to abduct him never arose? There were simply too many variables. But if they were working with an accomplice, this meant someone else could have taken care of the mail drop once the boy was taken. The task of overseeing the investigation was handed to local magistrate, 33-year-old Judge Jean-Michel Lambert. Gregory's murder was expected to be an open and shut case. All police had to do was identify the crow and they'd have the killer. They knew the caller came from within the Villemarne
如果他们这样做了，他们必须对绑架行动充满信心。他们怎么能确定格雷戈里会在外面玩？如果绑架他的机会从未出现怎么办？变量实在太多了。但如果他们有同伙，这意味着一旦男孩被带走，其他人可以负责投递邮件。监督调查的任务交给了当地地方法官，33岁的让-米歇尔·兰伯特法官。格雷戈里的谋杀案本应是一起简单明了的案件。警方所要做的就是查明“乌鸦”的身份，他们就能抓到凶手。他们知道打电话的人来自维尔曼
family, which narrowed down the suspect list significantly. But it wasn't as simple as it seemed. Gregory's grandmother, Monique Villemin, was one of 13 siblings alone. All up, the extended family consisted of over 140 individuals, and previous investigations to identify the caller had proved fruitless. During the Crow's peak time of activity, several recipients had managed to record the calls But the recordings weren't of particularly high quality The crow had made obvious attempts to disguise their voice, speaking in a hoarse, raspy tone Given the muffled sound, it was likely they'd covered the receiver with a handkerchief or piece of fabric. As it stood, nobody recognised the caller's voice. Police began questioning relatives of the Villemain family and verifying alibis.
家族内部，这大大缩小了嫌疑人名单。但这并不像看起来那么简单。格雷戈里的祖母莫妮克·维尔曼仅兄弟姐妹就有13人。总的来说，这个大家庭由140多人组成，之前的调查试图查明打电话的人，结果都徒劳无功。在“乌鸦”活动的高峰期，几位接收者设法录下了通话，但录音的质量不是特别高。“乌鸦”明显试图伪装自己的声音，用嘶哑、刺耳的语调说话。考虑到声音很闷，很可能是他们用手帕或布料遮住了听筒。目前，没有人认出打电话人的声音。警方开始盘问维尔曼家族的亲属并核实不在场证明。
They gathered handwriting samples to compare against the first and final letters sent to Jean-Marie. One was in block capitals, the other in cursive script. Individuals were required to write the message from the last letter with both their left and right hands. The samples were then sent to a handwriting expert for analysis. With so many relatives, it was a slow-moving process. Although Jean-Marie and Christine lived in a quiet spot on the outskirts of La Pange, it wasn't isolated. Several residents lived nearby and had been home or in the area at the time Gregory was abducted. It had still been broad daylight.
他们收集了笔迹样本，以便与寄给让-马里的第一封和最后一封信进行对比。一封是大写字母，另一封是连体字。个人被要求用左右手写出最后一封信中的信息。样本随后被送往笔迹专家进行分析。由于亲属众多，这是一个缓慢的过程。虽然让-马里和克里斯汀住在勒庞日郊区一个安静的地方，但它并不孤立。几位居民住在附近，在格雷戈里被绑架时都在家或在该地区。当时还是光天化日之下。
One local man had been walking his dog near the Villemans' property, but he hadn't seen any cars drive by or noticed anything of interest. Nor had any of the Villemans' neighbours. They were aware of the ongoing harassment from the Crow. Had they witnessed any suspicious activity near the property, they said they would have reported it. A man who lived further down the road recalled hearing a car drive up the hill at around 5.05pm, but he never heard it drive back down again. He never saw it, so couldn't vouch for the colour or model. In the days leading up to the crime, several townsfolk had noticed an
一位当地男子曾在维尔曼家附近遛狗，但他没有看到任何车辆经过，也没有注意到任何值得注意的事情。维尔曼家的邻居们也一样。他们知道“乌鸦”一直在进行骚扰。他们表示，如果他们目睹了房产附近的任何可疑活动，他们一定会报告。一位住在路更远处的男子回忆说，下午5点05分左右听到一辆车开上山，但他从未听到它开下来。他没看到那辆车，所以无法确定它的颜色或型号。在犯罪发生前的几天里，几位镇民注意到一辆
unfamiliar green car circulating the village. At around 2pm on the day Gregory was taken, one man recalled seeing a beige-coloured van parked near the woods overlooking the Villemans' home. A man and woman were inside. He didn't get a good look at them, but they appeared to have something hanging around their necks, possibly binoculars or a camera. This witness saw the same car driving towards Doselle, the village where Gregory's body was found, at 4.45pm. No other cars were seen driving between La Pange and Doselle during this key time frame. Hundreds of houses and several busy factories overlooked the Vallone River between the two villages. Dozens of people had spent time near the water on the night Gregory died, yet no one had witnessed anything out of the ordinary.
辆陌生的绿色汽车在村子里转悠。在格雷戈里被带走的那天下午2点左右，一名男子回忆说看到一辆米色的货车停在俯瞰维尔曼家住宅的树林附近。车里有一男一女。他没看清他们的长相，但他们脖子上似乎挂着什么东西，可能是双筒望远镜或照相机。这名目击者在下午4点45分看到同一辆车驶向多塞尔，即发现格雷戈里尸体的村庄。在这个关键的时间段内，没有看到其他车辆在拉潘热和多塞尔之间行驶。在这两个村庄之间，有数百座房屋和几家繁忙的工厂俯瞰着瓦洛内河。在格雷戈里去世的那天晚上，几十人在水边待过，但没有人目睹任何异常情况。
One woman had crossed the footbridge in Dosell at around 5.30. She recalled looking into the river and noticing what she thought was a garbage bag floating in the water. In hindsight, she wondered whether it could have been Gregory's body. The forensic pathologist deemed this unlikely. Although the exact time of death couldn't be confirmed, they believed Gregory had likely died sometime around 6pm. It was possible he might not have been thrown into the river until hours after he was killed. One local had witnessed a middle-aged man hanging around the Lepange post office around 5pm on October 15 and 16. He had brown curly hair, a strong build, and wore glasses. On October 22, six days after Gregory's death, the police released a composite sketch of
一名女子在5点30分左右穿过了多塞尔的人行天桥。她回忆说，看向河里时，注意到水里漂浮着一个她认为是垃圾袋的东西。事后回想起来，她怀疑那会不会是格雷戈里的尸体。法医病理学家认为这种可能性不大。虽然无法确定确切的死亡时间，但他们认为格雷戈里很可能是在下午6点左右去世的。他有可能是在被杀害数小时后才被扔进河里的。一名当地人曾目睹一名中年男子在10月15日和16日下午5点左右在勒潘热邮局附近徘徊。他留着棕色卷发，身材魁梧，戴着眼镜。10月22日，即格雷戈里去世六天后，警方发布了一张
this suspect, asking anyone who recognised the man to come forward. A local man voluntarily presented himself to police. He identified himself as the one in the sketch. He claimed he'd only been at the post office because he was waiting for a lift to work from a friend. Police confirmed this to be true, and the man and sketch were eliminated from the investigation. The press quickly picked up on the case, and journalists from all over France flocked to La Panche. The sleepy village instantly became a hive of activity. Journalists vied for the Villemans' attention, interviewing family members all over town in the hopes of unveiling some salacious details. If the Villemans were concealing any secrets, every media outlet wanted to be the first to break the story. Before long, more than 130 journalists stationed themselves around town.
这张嫌疑人的合成素描，要求任何认出该男子的人挺身而出。一名当地男子主动向警方自首。他确认自己就是素描中的那个人。他声称他去邮局只是因为在等朋友开车接他去上班。警方证实了这一点，该男子和素描被排除在调查之外。媒体迅速跟进了此案，来自法国各地的记者蜂拥至拉潘热。这个沉睡的村庄瞬间变得热闹非凡。记者们争相吸引维尔曼一家的注意，在全镇采访家庭成员，希望能揭露一些耸人听闻的细节。如果维尔曼一家隐瞒了什么秘密，每家媒体都想成为第一个报道的人。没过多久，就有130多名记者驻扎在镇上。
Lepange and Ormondzay were traditional villages. Residents were mostly private and shared the Villemans mentality that family conflicts should be sorted out within one's family. Therefore, the presence of the media wasn't particularly well received. When journalists poked around for information, they were often told to mind their own business. Others divulged gossip and rumours about the family that the press were quick to spread. One particularly salacious detail was that Gregory's grandmother had a history of incest in her family. Another was that Gregory's grandfather, Albert, had been raised in a broken home. When he was just a baby, his mother hit his three-year-old brother who suffered a fatal head wound. Albert's mother served time in prison. Upon her
勒潘热和奥尔蒙泽是传统的村庄。居民们大多比较内向，并认同维尔曼一家的观念，即家庭冲突应该在家庭内部解决。因此，媒体的出现并没有受到特别欢迎。当记者们打听消息时，他们经常被告知少管闲事。其他人则泄露了关于这个家庭的流言蜚语，媒体很快就将其传播开来。一个特别耸人听闻的细节是，格雷戈里的祖母家族有乱伦史。另一个细节是，格雷戈里的祖父阿尔伯特是在一个破碎的家庭中长大的。当他还是个婴儿时，他的母亲打伤了他三岁的哥哥，导致其头部受致命伤。阿尔伯特的母亲因此入狱。在她
release, she cheated on her husband, which became the catalyst for him ending his own life when Albert was just 12 years old. The press were quick to paint the Villemans as a lower class and socially marginalised bunch of hillbillies plagued by dark secrets. In reality, regardless of their sullied background, they were a relatively normal working-class family typical of the area. On Saturday October 20, Gregory Villemans' funeral was held at the L Panche Cemetery. Hundreds of mourners gathered, while members of the press hungrily snapped photographs of the bereaved family.
获释后，她背叛了丈夫，这成为了阿尔伯特12岁时父亲自杀的导火索。媒体很快将维尔曼一家描绘成一群被黑暗秘密困扰的、社会边缘化的底层乡巴佬。实际上，无论他们背景如何，他们只是该地区典型的相对正常的工薪阶层家庭。10月20日星期六，格雷戈里·维尔曼的葬礼在拉潘热公墓举行。数百名哀悼者聚集在一起，而媒体成员则贪婪地拍摄着悲痛欲绝的家属。
Police believed Gregory's killer was among the crowd and were on the lookout for any suspicious behaviour. It was a sombre affair, with emotions running high. Gregory's small body was carried out in a child-sized coffin, his beloved stuffed monkey Kiki to be buried by his side. His mother Christine clung to her husband as they shakily made their way through the procession. As Gregory's coffin was lowered to the ground, Christine wailed in despair. Gregory, my baby, why did they do this to you? Gregory, come back. It all became too much for Christine, who collapsed. Loved ones hurried to carry her unconscious body away as photographers eagerly
警方认为格雷戈里的凶手就在人群中，并一直在寻找任何可疑行为。这是一场沉痛的仪式，情绪高涨。格雷戈里小小的遗体被装在儿童大小的棺材里抬了出来，他心爱的毛绒猴子基基也将被埋在他身边。他的母亲克里斯汀紧紧抓住丈夫，颤抖着穿过送葬队伍。当格雷戈里的棺材被放下时，克里斯汀绝望地哀号起来。格雷戈里，我的孩子，他们为什么要这样对你？格雷戈里，回来吧。这一切对克里斯汀来说太沉重了，她晕倒了。亲人们急忙抬走她失去知觉的身体，而摄影师们则急切地
captured the drama. On Monday October 22, six days after Gregory's death, the police received an unprompted phone call from a local woman named Marie-Ange Laroche. She had married into the Villemin family and harboured some suspicions of her own. Marie-Ange urged the police to look into Jean-Marie's half-brother, Jackie. She believed that Jackie and his wife, Lillian, were behind the crow. Police questioned Jackie, but he had an airtight alibi for the day of Gregory's murder. Unbeknown to the rest of his family, Jackie's wife, Lillian, had actually received a call from the crow seven months earlier in March of 1984. The crow had spoken of his resentment for Jean-Marie and his plan to
捕捉到了这一戏剧性的一幕。10月22日星期一，即格雷戈里去世六天后，警方接到了当地一名叫玛丽-安吉·拉罗什的女子打来的主动电话。她嫁入了维尔曼家族，并有自己的一些怀疑。玛丽-安吉敦促警方调查让-马里的同父异母兄弟杰基。她认为杰基和他的妻子莉莲是“乌鸦”背后的主使。警方审问了杰基，但他有格雷戈里遇害当天的确凿不在场证明。在家族其他成员不知情的情况下，杰基的妻子莉莲实际上在七个月前的1984年3月接到过“乌鸦”的电话。“乌鸦”谈到了他对让-马里的怨恨，以及他计划
cast suspicion against Lillian and her father. Once again, he ranted about Jackie's illegitimate status and the alleged infidelities of his mother, Monique. Lillian had recorded the call and provided it as proof of her and her husband's innocence Police believed it to be genuine Jackie and Lillian Villemain were not the Crow Police found the accusation levelled against the couple by Marie-Ange Laroche unusual It was merely based on the time Jackie had left his house on the morning of the crime. It had nothing to do with anything. They also found it strange that Marie-Ange called the police from a public telephone instead of her own home.
将怀疑引向莉莲和她的父亲。他再次喋喋不休地谈论杰基的私生子身份以及他母亲莫妮克所谓的通奸行为。莉莲录下了通话内容，并将其作为她和丈夫清白的证据。警方认为这是真实的。杰基和莉莲·维尔曼不是“乌鸦”。警方发现玛丽-安吉·拉罗什对这对夫妇的指控很不寻常。这仅仅是基于杰基在案发当天早上离开家的时间。这与任何事情都无关。他们还觉得奇怪的是，玛丽-安吉是从公用电话而不是她自己家里给警方打电话的。
Perhaps she didn't want someone in her house to hear. of her own home. Perhaps she didn't want someone in her house to hear. Marie Arnge was summoned to the police station to provide a statement. She explained that she'd called from a public phone so that she wouldn't wake her husband, who was sleeping in preparation for a night shift. It was he who suggested that she contact authorities. In addition to Jackie and Liliane, Marie-Ange implicated some distant relatives of the Villemans, married couple Chantal and Daniel Ollard.
也许她不想让家里的人听到。也许她不想让家里的人听到。玛丽-安吉被传唤到警察局提供陈述。她解释说，她从公用电话打来是为了不吵醒正在为夜班做准备而睡觉的丈夫。是他建议她联系当局的。除了杰基和莉莲，玛丽-安吉还牵连了维尔曼家的一些远房亲戚，一对已婚夫妇尚塔尔和丹尼尔·奥拉德。
Police visited Chantal and Daniel to see if Marie-Ange's allegations held any weight. They conducted a search of the couple's home, but found nothing to link them to the crime. Chantel and Daniel were taken into custody for questioning but quickly ruled out of the investigation. When asked where she was on the afternoon Gregory Villemin was killed, Marie-Ange Laroche said she'd been at work. Her alibi checked out, but she'd been off work sick since October 18, two days after Gregory's death. Police found this curious. Everything about her unsolicited statement had them asking
警方拜访了尚塔尔和丹尼尔，看看玛丽-安吉的指控是否有分量。他们搜查了这对夫妇的家，但没有发现任何将他们与犯罪联系起来的证据。尚塔尔和丹尼尔被拘留审问，但很快被排除在调查之外。当被问及格雷戈里·维尔曼遇害那天下午她在哪里时，玛丽-安吉·拉罗什说她在上班。她的不在场证明得到了证实，但她自10月18日（格雷戈里去世两天后）起就因病请假了。警方觉得这很奇怪。关于她主动提供的陈述，一切都让他们产生
questions. Was it possible that Marie Ange was casting blame on other members of the family to detract attention from her own? Police soon visited Marie Ange Laroche's home in Ormondzay to question her husband, 29-year-old Bernard Laroche. Bernard was a cousin of Jean-Marie Villemin. The two had grown up together, but they'd drifted apart over the years. Yet, they lived somewhat parallel lives. somewhat parallel lives. Both worked as factory foremen in different organisations, and both had four-year-old sons born just ten days apart. Although they didn't talk much anymore,
疑问。玛丽-安吉是否有可能为了转移对自己家庭成员的注意力而将责任推给其他人？警方很快拜访了位于奥尔蒙泽的玛丽-安吉·拉罗什家，审问她的丈夫，29岁的伯纳德·拉罗什。伯纳德是让-马里·维尔曼的表兄弟。两人从小一起长大，但多年来关系疏远了。然而，他们过着某种平行生活。两人都在不同的机构担任工厂领班，并且都有一个仅相差十天出生的四岁儿子。虽然他们不再多说话，
Bernard maintained a close friendship with Jean-Marie's brother, Michel. The two considered each other best friends and saw each other regularly. Bernard told police that on the day Gregory was abducted, he'd spent most of the day with his aunt, Louisette Jacob. She lived just 200 metres from the La Roche's home. In the afternoon, Bernard chopped wood. He and his four-year-old son, Sebastian, then visited Michelle Wilman at his home around the corner. At 4.30pm, they returned to Aunt Louisette's. Bernard had arranged to meet a friend there so they could go buy some wine together, but the friend never arrived. Instead, Bernard drove to his friend's house, but he wasn't there either.
伯纳德与让-马里的兄弟米歇尔保持着密切的友谊。两人互为挚友，经常见面。伯纳德告诉警方，在格雷戈里被绑架的那天，他大部分时间都和他的姨妈路易塞特·雅各布在一起。她住在离拉罗什家仅200米的地方。下午，伯纳德在砍柴。随后，他和四岁的儿子塞巴斯蒂安去拜访了住在拐角处的米歇尔·维尔曼。下午4点30分，他们回到了路易塞特姨妈家。伯纳德原本安排在那里见一位朋友，这样他们就可以一起去买些酒，但那位朋友一直没来。相反，伯纳德开车去了朋友家，但他也不在那里。
Bernard returned to his aunt's house at around 5.30pm. He hung around for about 15 minutes before driving to the supermarket to buy the wine. At this point, it was roughly 6pm. He bought the wine, then headed to the nearby hotel to pick up some money he'd won on a recent bet. He then returned to Aunt Louisette's for dinner before leaving to work the night shift at around 8.45pm. Bernard claimed he didn't hear about Gregory Villemain's murder until the following morning. When asked to provide a handwriting sample, Bernard was reluctant. It was only after insistence from Marie Ange that he finally obliged. He was then free to leave. Police reflected on Bernard's movements from the day in question.
伯纳德在下午5点30分左右回到了姨妈家。他待了大约15分钟，然后开车去超市买酒。此时大约是下午6点。他买了酒，然后前往附近的酒店领取他最近赌博赢来的一笔钱。之后，他回到路易塞特姨妈家吃晚饭，然后在晚上8点45分左右离开去上夜班。伯纳德声称直到第二天早上才听说格雷戈里·维尔曼被谋杀的消息。当被要求提供笔迹样本时，伯纳德很不情愿。直到玛丽-安吉坚持要求，他才最终照办。随后他被获准离开。警方回顾了伯纳德在案发当天的行踪。
Curiously, there was only a 45-minute window that was unaccounted for, between 4.45 and 5.30pm. The same time that Gregory was abducted. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Michelle Cornelie owned a cafe in Doselle, not far from where Gregory's body was found. On the afternoon that the boy went missing, Mr Cornelie had noticed a strange man sitting in his establishment. He'd been there between 4.35 and 4.40pm and again between 5 and 5.15pm.
奇怪的是，只有45分钟的时间段无法解释，即下午4点45分到5点30分之间。这正是格雷戈里被绑架的时间。Case File节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。米歇尔·科尔内利在多塞尔拥有一家咖啡馆，离发现格雷戈里尸体的地方不远。在男孩失踪的那天下午，科尔内利先生注意到一个陌生的男人坐在他的店里。他在下午4点35分到4点40分之间，以及下午5点到5点15分之间都在那里。
He looked nervous and kept glancing at both his watch and the cafe's clock. The man looked to be aged in his late 20s or early 30s. He had a thick mop of brown hair and a thick brown moustache that came to the corners of his mouth. Another witness had spotted a similar looking man lurking around Gregory's school the day of and before the crime. Only this one had a thicker moustache that dropped onto his chin and was driving a green car. Around 5pm on October 16, this witness spotted the same man near the La Pange garbage dump just a short distance from Gregory's home. Both Mr Cornelie and the school witness had helped police create a composite sketch of this man.
他看起来很紧张，不停地看手表和咖啡馆的时钟。这个男人看起来有20多岁或30出头。他留着浓密的棕色头发，嘴边留着浓密的棕色胡子。另一名目击者在案发当天和前一天在格雷戈里的学校附近看到过一个长相相似的男人。只是这个人的胡子更浓，一直垂到下巴，开着一辆绿色汽车。10月16日下午5点左右，这名目击者在离格雷戈里家不远的拉潘热垃圾场附近看到了同一个男人。科尔内利先生和学校的目击者都协助警方制作了这个男人的合成素描。
There was no denying the uncanny resemblance to Bernard Laroche. Bernard also drove a metallic greenish-grey Peugeot 305. A car of similar colour had been seen circling La Pange in the days leading up to Gregory's abduction. A team of handwriting experts were tasked with comparing the letters from the crow to the handwriting samples provided by numerous family members. They announced their cursory findings, stating that the writing on the final letter from the crow matched that of Bernard Laroche. They'd also discovered something else of interest, handwriting impressions from another piece of paper. One of the handwriting experts highlighted the imprint with a special toner and placed the piece of paper against a grazing light.
不可否认，这与伯纳德·拉罗什有着惊人的相似之处。伯纳德也开着一辆金属绿灰色的标致305。在格雷戈里被绑架前的几天里，有人看到一辆颜色相似的汽车在拉潘热转悠。一组笔迹专家受命将“乌鸦”的信件与众多家庭成员提供的笔迹样本进行比较。他们宣布了初步调查结果，称“乌鸦”最后一封信上的笔迹与伯纳德·拉罗什的笔迹相符。他们还发现了另一个有趣的东西，即来自另一张纸的笔迹压痕。其中一名笔迹专家用特殊的调色剂突出了压痕，并将那张纸放在侧光下。
At the bottom of the paper, two letters were clearly visible, B and L. The initials were superimposed against Bernard LaRoche's signature. There were undeniable similarities. The team wanted more time to conduct tests and confirm for sure, but for the police, this was all they needed to hear. The following day, they went to the La Roche residence and placed Bernard under arrest. His wife, Marie Arnch, was detained as a witness. A search of the La Roche home uncovered a record of the Grand Jojo song We Are Thirsty, a song which the crow had played to the Vilmars. A telescope was also found. The La Roche's house was positioned on a hill,
在纸的底部，两个字母清晰可见，B和L。这些首字母与伯纳德·拉罗什的签名重叠在一起。存在不可否认的相似之处。团队希望有更多时间进行测试并确认，但对警方来说，这就是他们需要听到的全部。第二天，他们前往拉罗什住所，将伯纳德逮捕。他的妻子玛丽-安吉作为证人被拘留。对拉罗什家的搜查发现了一张大乔乔的歌曲《我们口渴了》的唱片，这是“乌鸦”曾放给维尔曼一家听的歌。还发现了一台望远镜。拉罗什家位于山上，
with views towards the homes of Gregory's grandparents Albert and Monique, and Gregory's uncle Michel. It was possible Bernard had watched their comings and goings with this telescope and used this information to taunt them with. Bernard claimed he didn't need a telescope to see Albert and Monique's house, and that even with one, Michelle's house still wasn't visible. According to Bernard, his father had given him the telescope 15 years prior, and it hadn't been used for some time. Bernard's father, Marcel, had died in June 1982, a little over two and a half years before Gregory
视野可以俯瞰格雷戈里的祖父母阿尔伯特和莫妮克，以及格雷戈里的叔叔米歇尔的家。伯纳德有可能用这台望远镜观察他们的行踪，并利用这些信息来嘲弄他们。伯纳德声称他不需要望远镜就能看到阿尔伯特和莫妮克的家，而且即使有望远镜，也看不到米歇尔的家。据伯纳德说，他父亲在15年前给了他这台望远镜，而且已经有一段时间没用了。伯纳德的父亲马塞尔于1982年6月去世，距离格雷戈里
was killed. In the search, police found a note Marcel had written that claimed, Albert is blackmailing me. They wondered if Bernard could be motivated to seek revenge on the Villemarne family on behalf of his father, to whom he was very close. But Bernard said he'd found the note after his father's death. He claimed it didn't relate to Albert Villemarne, but to his maternal uncle, Albert Jacob. Wilman, but to his maternal uncle, Albert Jacob. Bernard strongly denied having anything to do with Gregory Wilman's death. An officer asked if he'd ever sent threatening letters to the Wilman family. Bernard responded, never. I have nothing against them. Think, why would I do that? Tell me, why in the end? It was a legitimate question. Although the circumstantial evidence was stacking up against
遇害还有两年半多一点的时间。在搜查中，警方发现了一张马塞尔写的便条，上面写着：“阿尔伯特在勒索我。”他们想知道伯纳德是否可能是为了他非常亲近的父亲而向维尔曼一家寻求报复。但伯纳德说他在父亲去世后才发现这张便条。他声称这与阿尔伯特·维尔曼无关，而是与他的舅舅阿尔伯特·雅各布有关。伯纳德强烈否认与格雷戈里·维尔曼的死有任何关系。一名警官问他是否曾给维尔曼一家寄过威胁信。伯纳德回答说：“从来没有。我对他们没有任何意见。想想看，我为什么要那样做？告诉我，到底为什么？”这是一个合理的问题。尽管间接证据堆积在
Bernard Laroche, police had yet to identify a compelling motive. police had yet to identify a compelling motive. No one in the family had previously suspected Bernard of being the Crow. He was very close with Gregory's uncle, Michelle, and maintained good relations with the family overall. He wasn't known to be an aggressive or shady person and remained impartial to any family conflicts. Upon reflection, these factors actually worked against him. Bernard saw Michelle several times a week and was privy to all that was going on in the Villemans'
伯纳德·拉罗什身上，但警方尚未确定一个令人信服的动机。家族中没有人曾怀疑伯纳德是“乌鸦”。他与格雷戈里的叔叔米歇尔非常亲近，与整个家庭保持着良好的关系。他并不以好斗或阴险的人而闻名，并且对任何家庭冲突保持中立。回想起来，这些因素实际上对他不利。伯纳德每周见米歇尔几次，并了解维尔曼一家生活中发生的一切。
lives. He lived close to Gregory's grandparents and was present at family gatherings. This not only meant he had access to the information divulged by the Crow, he was also close enough to witness the impact of the Crow's ongoing harassment. The LaRoche family had a phone line installed in 1981, coinciding with the calls to Jean-Marie and Christine Villemin. Their house also had a staircase. During several of the Crow's phone calls, several recipients thought they could hear someone climbing steps in the background. Criminal profilers believed the Crow likely presented themselves to the world as pleasant and somewhat withdrawn. They would avoid drawing attention to themselves by being amicable and friendly. Behind closed doors, it was a different story. The crow was likely driven by hate,
他住在离格雷戈里的祖父母很近的地方，并出席家庭聚会。这意味着他不仅能接触到“乌鸦”泄露的信息，而且离得足够近，能目睹“乌鸦”持续骚扰的影响。拉罗什家在1981年安装了电话线，这与打给让-马里和克里斯汀·维尔曼的电话时间相吻合。他们的房子里也有楼梯。在“乌鸦”的几次电话中，几位接听者认为他们能听到背景中有人爬楼梯的声音。犯罪侧写师认为，“乌鸦”很可能向世界展示自己是一个讨人喜欢且有些内向的人。他们会通过表现得和蔼可亲来避免引起对他人的注意。在闭门之后，情况就不同了。乌鸦很可能是由仇恨、
jealousy, and resentment. Bernard had most of the things that his cousin, Jean-Marie Villemin, had, but nothing came quite as easy. Bernard's mother had died shortly after giving birth. He and his father went to live with his maternal grandparents. Jean-Marie, on the other hand, had enjoyed a relatively normal childhood, surrounded by his parents and siblings. It had taken Bernard six years of hard work and study to prove himself worthy of the position of factory foreman, and not until his late twenties. In contrast, Jean-Marie's foreman role had been handed to him at a young age without significant effort or any qualifications. His role also paid better. Bernard's marriage to Marie-Ange had been marred with arguments and accusations of infidelity
嫉妒和怨恨驱动的。伯纳德拥有他表兄弟让-马里·维尔曼拥有的大部分东西，但没有什么是轻易得到的。伯纳德的母亲在生下他后不久就去世了。他和父亲去和外祖父母住在一起。另一方面，让-马里享受着相对正常的童年，被父母和兄弟姐妹包围着。伯纳德花了六年时间的努力工作和学习才证明自己有资格担任工厂领班，而且直到二十多岁后期才实现。相比之下，让-马里的领班职位是在年轻时就交给他的，没有付出重大努力或任何资格。他的职位薪水也更高。伯纳德与玛丽-安吉的婚姻因争吵和通奸指控而受损。
Jean-Marie's marriage to Christine was harmonious and solid Even fatherhood had presented Bernard with a unique challenge His son, Sebastian, had been born with a large cyst on his left temple. It was surgically removed but had to be constantly drained by a tube behind his ear. Because of this, Sebastian required constant supervision. Little Gregory Villemarne, on the other hand, had been the very picture of good health. hand, had been the very picture of good health. Christine Villemin recalled that Bernard had tried to hit on her at a family wedding several years prior. Perhaps he'd never recovered from the sting of the rejection and resented that Christine had chosen Jean-Marie over him.
让-马里与克里斯汀的婚姻和谐稳固。甚至为人父也给伯纳德带来了独特的挑战。他的儿子塞巴斯蒂安出生时左太阳穴上有一个大囊肿。它被手术切除了，但必须通过耳后的一根管子不断引流。因此，塞巴斯蒂安需要持续的监护。另一方面，小格雷戈里·维尔曼却是健康的化身。克里斯汀·维尔曼回忆说，伯纳德几年前在一次家庭婚礼上曾试图勾引她。也许他从未从被拒绝的刺痛中恢复过来，并怨恨克里斯汀选择了让-马里而不是他。
De Croo had been fixated on Jackie Villne's illegitimate status within the family. He had alleged there was another, quote, bastard child among them. Rumours spread that Bernard could have in fact been Albert Villemarne's biological son. If Bernard was suspicious of this, it could explain his resentment towards Albert. Perhaps he begrudged the fact that Albert had taken responsibility for Jackie, but not for his own flesh and blood. Bernard's close friendship with Michel Villemin was also significant. Michel was known to be immature and naive. Michel was known to be immature and naive. He harboured unhealthy jealousy towards people he viewed as above him, in particular his brother, Jean-Marie.
“乌鸦”一直盯着杰基·维尔曼在家族中的私生子身份。他声称他们中间还有另一个“杂种”孩子。有传言称，伯纳德实际上可能是阿尔伯特·维尔曼的亲生儿子。如果伯纳德对此有怀疑，这可以解释他对阿尔伯特的怨恨。也许他嫉妒阿尔伯特承担了杰基的责任，却没有承担他自己亲生骨肉的责任。伯纳德与米歇尔·维尔曼的亲密友谊也很重要。米歇尔被认为是不成熟和天真的。他对他认为地位高于自己的人怀有不健康的嫉妒，特别是他的兄弟让-马里。
Inferiority was a real soft spot for Michel, and his fits of envy had previously caused many conflicts within the family. Shortly before Gregory's death, Michel Villemin and his wife had visited Jean-Marie and Christine's home. The couple had showed off their new leather lounge suite and talked about their plans to extend their house. It was highly likely that Michel told Bernard about this visit. If Bernard Laroche harboured intense feelings of jealousy and inadequacy towards Jean-Marie, investigators believed this could have been enough to finally push him over the edge. Shortly after Gregory's death, Bernard had told journalist Jean Caire from Paris Match magazine, "...they got what they deserved. They've paid for what they've done. Bernard Laroche maintained his story about going to find his friend during the crucial time period
自卑感是米歇尔的一个真正的软肋，他的嫉妒发作此前曾在家族中引起过许多冲突。在格雷戈里去世前不久，米歇尔·维尔曼和他的妻子拜访了让-马里和克里斯汀的家。这对夫妇炫耀了他们新的真皮沙发套，并谈论了他们扩建房子的计划。米歇尔很有可能告诉了伯纳德这次访问。如果伯纳德·拉罗什对让-马里怀有强烈的嫉妒和无能感，调查人员认为这可能足以最终将他推向边缘。格雷戈里去世后不久，伯纳德告诉《巴黎竞赛》杂志的记者让·凯尔：“……他们得到了他们应得的。他们为他们所做的一切付出了代价。”伯纳德·拉罗什坚持他关于在关键时间段去寻找朋友的说法，
on Tuesday October 16. He said that when he returned to his aunt Louisette's house at around 5.30pm, his sister-in-law Muriel Boll was there watching television. Police questioned Muriel. The 15-year-old high school student had recently moved in with the LaRoches to help take care of their son. She confirmed that on the afternoon of October 16 she'd taken the bus home from school. Muriel went to her aunt Louisette's house at around 5.20pm. Bernard Laroche was already there. He was sitting in the kitchen with his son in his lap, watching television. Given that Gregory Villemin had been abducted sometime after 5.03pm, this meant Bernard wouldn't have had enough time to pull off the crime. With his alibi verified,
即10月16日星期二。他说，当他在下午5点30分左右回到路易塞特姨妈家时，他的嫂子穆里尔·博尔正在那里看电视。警方审问了穆里尔。这位15岁的高中生最近搬进了拉罗什家，帮忙照顾他们的儿子。她证实，10月16日下午，她乘公共汽车从学校回家。穆里尔在下午5点20分左右去了路易塞特姨妈家。伯纳德·拉罗什已经在那里了。他坐在厨房里，怀里抱着儿子，看着电视。鉴于格雷戈里·维尔曼是在下午5点03分之后的某个时间被绑架的，这意味着伯纳德没有足够的时间来实施犯罪。随着他的不在场证明得到证实，
police had no choice but to let him go. However, investigators reviewing the statements soon noticed a discrepancy. Bernard said when he'd arrived at Louisette's house, Muriel was there watching television. However, Muriel gave the reverse. She said that Bernard was already there when she arrived after school. Something wasn't right. to school. Something wasn't right. Muriel had told police that her usual bus driver dropped her home on the afternoon in question. Police made inquiries around Muriel's high school and discovered that the usual driver hadn't been working that day. Several of Muriel's classmates recalled that she hadn't been on the bus at all.
警方别无选择，只能放他走。然而，审查陈述的调查人员很快发现了一个差异。伯纳德说，当他到达路易塞特家时，穆里尔正在那里看电视。然而，穆里尔给出的情况正好相反。她说，当她放学后到达时，伯纳德已经在那里了。有些事情不对劲。穆里尔告诉警方，她通常乘坐的公交车司机在案发当天下午把她送回了家。警方在穆里尔的高中进行了调查，发现通常的司机那天并没有上班。穆里尔的几位同学回忆说，她根本没有坐那辆车。
Muriel had a distinct head of curly red hair and a face full of freckles, so her absence was easily noted. One friend recalled seeing Muriel leave school in a khaki green vehicle that matched the description of Bernard LaRoche's Peugeot. Police confronted Muriel with this discrepancy. It didn't take long for her to crack. She admitted she'd lied about catching the bus home. According to Muriel, when she finished school on October 16, Bernard was waiting out the front in his car. His son Sebastian was with him. Bernard called Muriel over. It was the first time he had ever
穆里尔有一头明显的卷曲红发和满脸雀斑，所以她的缺席很容易被注意到。一位朋友回忆说，看到穆里尔坐上一辆卡其绿色的车离开学校，这与伯纳德·拉罗什的标致车的描述相符。警方用这个差异与穆里尔对质。没过多久她就崩溃了。她承认她撒谎说坐公交车回家。据穆里尔说，当她在10月16日放学时，伯纳德正开着车在前面等她。他的儿子塞巴斯蒂安和他在一起。伯纳德叫穆里尔过去。这是他第一次
picked Muriel up from school. She assumed it was because he needed someone to babysit Sebastian. to babysit Sebastian. She hopped in. Bernard drove them to La Panche. Muriel wasn't familiar with the area. Her parents didn't have a car, so she didn't know the surrounding region well. They drove up a hill and Bernard parked on the side of the road. Muriel could see a white house with a red roof. Bernard got out but didn't explain why. He walked towards the house. Muriel stayed in the car with Sebastian. When Bernard returned shortly afterwards, he had a small boy with him who was wearing a woolen hat. Muriel hadn't seen the child before, but he looked to be the same age as Sebastian. The boy got into the back seat. Bernard made one more quick stop in
从学校接穆里尔。她以为是因为他需要人照顾塞巴斯蒂安。她跳上了车。伯纳德开车把他们带到了拉潘热。穆里尔对这个地区不熟悉。她的父母没有车，所以她不太了解周边地区。他们开车上了一座山，伯纳德把车停在路边。穆里尔可以看到一栋红顶白墙的房子。伯纳德下了车，但没有解释原因。他朝房子走去。穆里尔和塞巴斯蒂安留在车里。当伯纳德不久后回来时，他带着一个小男孩，戴着羊毛帽。穆里尔以前没见过这个孩子，但他看起来和塞巴斯蒂安同龄。男孩上了后座。伯纳德在
Lepange, then drove the group to another village that Muriel wasn't familiar with. Bernard got out, taking the boy with him. She wasn't sure how long Bernard was gone for, but when he returned, he was alone. They then drove back to Aunt Louisette's house, arriving around 5.30pm. Bernard left to buy wine before returning home and then eventually leaving for his night shift at the factory. The next morning, Muriel saw a story about Gregory Villemin's murder in the newspaper. She immediately recognised him as the boy in the car and knew that Bernard was responsible. At the request of police, Muriel drew a sketch of their routes and the places they stopped in Lepange and Doselle.
勒潘热又做了一次快速停留，然后开车把他们带到了另一个穆里尔不熟悉的村庄。伯纳德下了车，带着男孩一起。她不确定伯纳德离开了多久，但当他回来时，他是一个人。然后他们开车回到路易塞特姨妈家，大约在下午5点30分到达。伯纳德离开去买酒，然后回家，最后离开去工厂上夜班。第二天早上，穆里尔在报纸上看到了关于格雷戈里·维尔曼谋杀案的报道。她立刻认出他就是车里的那个男孩，并知道伯纳德是罪魁祸首。应警方要求，穆里尔画了一张他们路线的草图，以及他们在勒潘热和多塞尔停留的地方。
The locations coincided with both the Villemarne residence and where Gregory's body had been found. Muriel told police she was relieved to get this off her chest. She explained, I didn't say anything in the days following the tragedy because I was afraid to talk about it. I lied so that my brother-in-law and my sister wouldn't be bothered. I thought it was better to tell the truth because it was too serious a thing to hide. Police were stunned by Muriel's confession.
这些地点与维尔曼住所和发现格雷戈里尸体的地方相吻合。穆里尔告诉警方，她很高兴能把这件事说出来。她解释说：“在悲剧发生后的几天里，我什么也没说，因为我害怕谈论它。我撒谎是为了让我的姐夫和姐姐不被打扰。我认为说出真相更好，因为这是一件太严重的事情，不能隐瞒。”警方对穆里尔的供述感到震惊。
Concerned she could be making it up to get attention, they gave her the option to recant her statement. Muriel declined, adamant that she was telling the truth. She stated, It's true. I remember it perfectly. I will remember it all my life. The presiding magistrate, Judge Jean-Michel Lambert, was out of town when Muriel confessed. It was therefore decided that no action would be taken until his return. Three days later, on Monday November 5, Judge Lambert met with Muriel. She repeated her confession, saying she hadn't come forward earlier because she was afraid of Bernard.
担心她可能是为了博取关注而编造的，他们给了她撤回陈述的机会。穆里尔拒绝了，坚持说她在说实话。她说：“这是真的。我记得很清楚。我一生都会记得。”主持法官让-米歇尔·兰伯特在穆里尔供述时不在城里。因此决定在他回来之前不采取任何行动。三天后，即11月5日星期一，兰伯特法官会见了穆里尔。她重复了她的供述，说她没有早点站出来是因为她害怕伯纳德。
Bernard Laroche was immediately arrested and charged with the murder of Gregory Villemin. Bernard's family were devastated. Marie Arnge tearfully told journalists there was no way her husband was guilty. She said he couldn't even kill a rabbit. It was a sentiment shared by others. It was a sentiment shared by others. Jackie Villemarne told the press that if Bernard was guilty, it was a Jekyll and Hyde situation. Even Gregory's parents found it hard to believe, with Jean-Marie telling reporters that he could no longer trust anyone. He'd always found Bernard to be helpful and kind. He stated, If it's really him, let justice be served.
伯纳德·拉罗什立即被捕，并被控谋杀格雷戈里·维尔曼。伯纳德的家人悲痛欲绝。玛丽-安吉含泪告诉记者，她的丈夫绝不可能有罪。她说他连兔子都杀不了。其他人也持有这种观点。杰基·维尔曼告诉媒体，如果伯纳德有罪，那就像是杰基尔和海德的情况。甚至格雷戈里的父母也觉得难以置信，让-马里告诉记者，他再也不能信任任何人了。他一直觉得伯纳德乐于助人且善良。他表示：“如果真的是他，让正义得到伸张吧。”
A press conference was held during which Judge Lambert revealed that Muriel Boll was a partial witness and had been in the car with Bernard. This was a big mistake. Bernard. This was a big mistake. At the time, there was nothing in French law that protected a minor from being taken into custody. Muriel was only 15. She had learning difficulties and was in a special education class at school. Muriel hadn't been offered a lawyer or advised of her right to remain silent. By publicly releasing her name, Judge Lambert had essentially outed Muriel to her entire family. The following day, journalists were summoned to the home of Bernard and Marie-Ange Laroche. The family had an announcement to make. As the press gathered outside, Muriel approached their microphones.
举行了一场新闻发布会，兰伯特法官在会上透露，穆里尔·博尔是一名部分证人，曾和伯纳德在车里。这是一个巨大的错误。当时，法国法律中没有任何保护未成年人免受拘留的规定。穆里尔只有15岁。她有学习障碍，在学校上特殊教育班。穆里尔没有被提供律师，也没有被告知她有保持沉默的权利。通过公开披露她的名字，兰伯特法官实际上向她的整个家庭曝光了穆里尔。第二天，记者们被传唤到伯纳德和玛丽-安吉·拉罗什的家中。这家人要发表声明。当媒体聚集在外面时，穆里尔走到麦克风前。
Stone-faced and with her chin quivering slightly, she said, I wasn't in Bernard's car. I have never been to La Panche or Doselle. I never went to that place where that kid was drowned. Muriel admitted she'd made the whole story up. She said the police told her that Bernard Laroche had already confessed to the crime before feeding her details. They threatened to send her to a reformatory school if she didn't go along with the confession. Muriel claimed she only complied out of fear. As for the sketches of the routes they supposedly took, Muriel said a police officer had shown her these locations. She was simply repeating his instructions. Muriel said she took the bus
她面无表情，下巴微微颤抖，说道：“我没有在伯纳德的车里。我从来没有去过拉潘热或多塞尔。我从来没有去过那个孩子被淹死的地方。”穆里尔承认她编造了整个故事。她说警方告诉她，伯纳德·拉罗什在向她提供细节之前就已经承认了罪行。他们威胁说，如果她不配合供述，就把她送到教养学校。穆里尔声称她只是出于恐惧才服从的。至于他们所谓的路线草图，穆里尔说是一名警官向她展示了这些地点。她只是在重复他的指示。穆里尔说她坐公交车
home as usual on October 16 and didn't see Bernard at all that day. She told the reporters, Bernard is innocent, Bernard is innocent. I never went with my brother-in-law. I never went with my brother-in-law. Muriel went to the courthouse and formally retracted her previous statement. Judge Lambert was undeterred. Even without the teenager's confession, he believed there was enough evidence against Bernard Laroche to secure a conviction for Gregory Villemain's murder. Bernard remained in custody as investigators continued building their case against him. For many, Muriel's retraction didn't exonerate Bernard. In fact, it had the opposite effect.
10月16日像往常一样回家，那天根本没见到伯纳德。她告诉记者：“伯纳德是无辜的，伯纳德是无辜的。我从来没有和我的姐夫一起去过。我从来没有和我的姐夫一起去过。”穆里尔去了法院，正式撤回了她之前的陈述。兰伯特法官不为所动。即使没有这个青少年的供述，他也认为有足够的证据证明伯纳德·拉罗什犯有谋杀格雷戈里·维尔曼的罪行。伯纳德继续被拘留，调查人员继续针对他建立案件。对许多人来说，穆里尔的撤回并没有使伯纳德免罪。事实上，它产生了相反的效果。
A neighbour of the Laroche family told the press that on the night Bernard was arrested, he overheard Muriel being beaten by her family Bernard's wife, Marie Arnch, strongly denied this accusation A family member later explained that they'd thrown rocks at trespassing journalists, which could have accounted for the noise at trespassing journalists, which could have accounted for the noise. Marie Arnge told reporters the family had no influence over Muriel whatsoever. Muriel backed this up. She maintained the police had scared her into providing the confession and she'd only come forward with the truth because she needed to clear Bernard's name. come forward with the truth because she needed to clear Bernard's name.
拉罗什家的一位邻居告诉媒体，在伯纳德被捕的那天晚上，他听到穆里尔被家人殴打。伯纳德的妻子玛丽-安吉强烈否认了这一指控。一位家庭成员后来解释说，他们向擅自闯入的记者扔石头，这可能是噪音的原因。玛丽-安吉告诉记者，这个家庭对穆里尔没有任何影响。穆里尔证实了这一点。她坚持认为警方吓唬她提供了供述，她之所以说出真相，是因为她需要洗清伯纳德的名字。
By Friday November 9, 24 days had passed since Gregory Villemin was killed. All of the individuals Bernard Laroche had mentioned crossing paths with on the afternoon of Gregory's death were assembled at the local courthouse. Hundreds of angry locals gathered outside, hoping to catch a glimpse of the alleged child killer and the other players in the story that continued to dominate national headlines. As Bernard was led from a police car, some members of the crowd chanted, Kill him. Kill him. He chanted, kill him, kill him.
到11月9日星期五，格雷戈里·维尔曼遇害已经过去了24天。伯纳德·拉罗什在格雷戈里遇害那天下午提到过与之擦肩而过的所有人都聚集在当地法院。数百名愤怒的当地人聚集在外面，希望能看一眼这位所谓的杀童凶手以及继续占据全国头条新闻的故事中的其他参与者。当伯纳德被从警车中带出时，人群中的一些人高喊：“杀了他。杀了他。”
Witnesses were able to verify Bernard's movements for the entire day of October 16, save for that crucial 45-minute window where Gregory was abducted. Bernard's lawyer called for his immediate release. The request was denied. For Gregory's parents, the fact that Bernard had visited Gregory's uncle Michel on the day of the crime was highly suspicious. They knew how close the two cousins were and how jealous Michel was of Jean-Marie's success. On the night of Gregory's murder, Michel had also been so agitated that he'd been placed in police custody Although Michelle had reported receiving calls from the Crow over the years, he'd been alone every time It was no different when he received the final call announcing that Gregory had been killed What if this call hadn't actually taken place at all?
目击者能够核实伯纳德在10月16日全天的行踪，除了格雷戈里被绑架的那关键45分钟。伯纳德的律师要求立即释放他。请求被拒绝。对于格雷戈里的父母来说，伯纳德在案发当天拜访了格雷戈里的叔叔米歇尔这一事实非常可疑。他们知道这两个表兄弟有多亲近，也知道米歇尔有多嫉妒让-马里的成功。在格雷戈里遇害的那天晚上，米歇尔也因为情绪激动而被警方拘留。虽然米歇尔报告说多年来一直接到“乌鸦”的电话，但每次他都是一个人。当他接到宣布格雷戈里被杀的最后一个电话时，情况也没有什么不同。如果这个电话根本没有发生过呢？
Was it possible that Michelle was just following orders from someone else? Jean-Marie started prying Michelle for information, which deeply angered their parents. They'd always been very protective of Michelle, and the insinuation that he could have been involved in Gregory's death was something they weren't prepared to stand for. It caused a great rift in the family. Jean-Marie severed all ties with his parents completely. A groundskeeper was clearing out some fir trees on the riverbank behind the fire station in Doselle. It was right next to the location Muriel Boll claimed Bernard Laroche had gotten out of the car with Gregory. It was where investigators had concluded Gregory's body was put in the river before floating downstream.
米歇尔是否可能只是在听从别人的命令？让-马里开始向米歇尔打听信息，这深深激怒了他们的父母。他们一直非常保护米歇尔，暗示他可能参与了格雷戈里的死亡是他们无法容忍的。这在家庭中造成了巨大的裂痕。让-马里彻底断绝了与父母的所有联系。一名场地管理员正在清理多塞尔消防站后面河岸上的一些冷杉树。这就在穆里尔·博尔声称伯纳德·拉罗什带着格雷戈里下车的地方旁边。调查人员得出结论，格雷戈里的尸体就是在那里被放入河中，然后顺流而下的。
In nearby bushes, the groundskeeper found a hypodermic needle and a 2ml vial of insulin. They immediately notified the police. Used for the daily treatment of diabetes, when given in high doses, insulin can cause a person to slip into a hyperglycemic coma. The question was therefore raised as to whether Gregory could have been injected with insulin prior to being thrown in the river. This would explain the serene look on his face as well as the lack of defensive marks on his body. face as well as the lack of defensive marks on his body. The forensic pathologist who conducted Gregory's autopsy confirmed this was possible. However, they hadn't been instructed to run any toxicology testing, nor had they checked Gregory's body for any needle marks. When freelance journalist Sylvain Abba found out about the insulin, he began making inquiries and made a startling discovery.
在附近的灌木丛中，场地管理员发现了一根皮下注射针头和一个2毫升的胰岛素小瓶。他们立即通知了警方。胰岛素用于糖尿病的日常治疗，如果大剂量注射，会导致人陷入高血糖昏迷。因此，人们提出了一个问题：格雷戈里在被扔进河里之前是否被注射了胰岛素。这将解释他脸上安详的表情以及他身上缺乏防御性伤痕的原因。进行格雷戈里尸检的法医病理学家证实这是可能的。然而，他们没有被指示进行任何毒理学测试，也没有检查格雷戈里身上是否有针孔。当自由撰稿人西尔万·阿巴发现胰岛素的事情时，他开始进行调查，并有了惊人的发现。
Someone with ties to the investigation was indeed a diabetic. Muriel Boll's mother, Janine. Sylvain tracked down Janine's nurse. Sylvain tracked down Janine's nurse. She confirmed that Janine used the same brand of insulin and syringes as those found on the riverbank. Case magistrate Judge Jean-Michel Lambert didn't think the line of inquiry was worth pursuing further. It was common for diabetics to administer insulin in public places, and the brand was widely used, so the discovery wasn't necessarily attributed to the crime. Besides, some new witnesses had come forward with some much more compelling information.
确实有一位与调查有关的人患有糖尿病，那就是穆里尔·博尔的母亲珍妮。西尔万找到了珍妮的护士。西尔万找到了珍妮的护士。她证实珍妮使用的胰岛素和注射器品牌与在河岸边发现的一致。负责此案的法官让-米歇尔·兰伯特认为这条调查线索不值得进一步追查。糖尿病患者在公共场所注射胰岛素很常见，而且该品牌使用广泛，因此这一发现并不一定与犯罪有关。此外，一些新证人提供了更有说服力的信息。
At the textile factory where Christine Villemin worked, it was customary for employees to be let out just before 5pm so that those who needed to could make the 5 o'clock train. A majority of staff members took advantage of this, even if they had their own transport. even if they had their own transport. After clocking out on the afternoon of Tuesday October 16 1984, one employee was walking towards the La Panche post office to visit her sister who lived nearby. She saw one of her colleagues parked outside of the post office. It was Christine Villemarne. Moments later, another co-worker approached. They noticed Christine doing a U-turn in front of the building. She didn't drive towards Gregory's nanny's house like she claimed, but in the opposite direction. Two other co-workers came forward to report that they too had seen Christine Villemin at the Lepange post office straight after work. They had watched as she dropped at least one envelope into the mailbox.
在克里斯汀·维尔曼工作的纺织厂，员工通常在下午5点前下班，以便那些需要的人能赶上5点的火车。大多数员工都利用了这一点，即使他们有自己的交通工具。即使他们有自己的交通工具。1984年10月16日星期二下午下班后，一名员工正步行前往拉帕涅邮局去看望住在附近的姐姐。她看到一位同事把车停在邮局外。那是克里斯汀·维尔曼。片刻之后，另一位同事走近。他们注意到克里斯汀在建筑物前掉头。她并没有像她声称的那样开车去格雷戈里的保姆家，而是朝相反的方向行驶。另外两名同事站出来报告说，他们下班后也看到克里斯汀·维尔曼在勒帕涅邮局。他们看着她把至少一个信封投进了邮箱。
The final letter sent by the Crow had been postmarked 5.15pm. The investigation was getting bigger than the local police could handle. Under immense pressure to solve the increasingly turbulent case, Judge Lambert finally appointed the National Police to take over. They confronted Christine with the allegations that she'd been spotted at the post office on the afternoon her son was killed. Christine said that her colleagues were mistaken. She had been there the day before. Christine claimed that after finishing work on Monday, she'd posted a cheque for a mail order. Police contacted the company in question. They produced an invoice confirming they had indeed received a mail order from
“乌鸦”寄出的最后一封信邮戳时间为下午5点15分。调查规模变得越来越大，当地警方已无法应付。在解决这起日益动荡的案件的巨大压力下，兰伯特法官最终任命国家警察接手。他们就克里斯汀在儿子遇害当天下午被发现在邮局的指控与她对质。克里斯汀说她的同事弄错了。她是前一天去的。克里斯汀声称，周一工作结束后，她去寄了一张邮购支票。警方联系了相关公司。他们出具了一张发票，证实他们确实收到了来自
Christine Villemarne, which had been dated Monday October 15. When Christine described the outfit she'd worn on the Monday, it matched the description given by those who believed they'd seen her at the post office on the Tuesday. But for the new investigators, enough seeds of doubt had been planted to warrant the question. Could Christine Villemin have been involved in her son's murder? It was a possibility they'd considered from early on for a few reasons. Neighbours who had helped Christine look for Gregory when he first went missing hadn't recalled seeing the young boy play outside at all. They also hadn't seen anyone else in the area. This led some to doubt Christine's story from the get-go. Whoever posted the letter claiming
克里斯汀·维尔曼的邮购订单，日期为10月15日星期一。当克里斯汀描述她周一穿的衣服时，与那些认为周二在邮局看到她的人所描述的一致。但对于新的调查人员来说，怀疑的种子已经种下，足以引出一个问题：克里斯汀·维尔曼是否参与了她儿子的谋杀案？由于几个原因，这是他们从一开始就考虑过的一种可能性。当格雷戈里刚失踪时，曾帮助克里斯汀寻找他的邻居们根本不记得看到过这个小男孩在外面玩耍。他们也没有看到该地区有其他人。这让一些人从一开始就怀疑克里斯汀的说法。无论谁寄出了那封声称
the crime had to have full certainty that they'd have access to the boy and would be able to pull off the crime. As the boy's mother, Christine could ensure this. Gregory's post-mortem concluded that the four-year-old had died from drowning. A theory emerged that Gregory might have died by accident. that Gregory might have died by accident. Perhaps Christine had left him unsupervised while he was taking a bath and he'd either drowned or been electrocuted. Fearing the repercussions, she could have staged a crime to deflect attention from herself. Alternatively, she could have intentionally drowned him in the tub before disposing of his body in the Vallone River to place the blame on the crow. The problem with both of these theories was timing.
犯罪的信，都必须完全确定他们能接触到这个男孩，并能成功实施犯罪。作为男孩的母亲，克里斯汀可以确保这一点。格雷戈里的尸检结论是，这个四岁的孩子死于溺水。一种理论出现了，即格雷戈里可能是意外死亡。格雷戈里可能是意外死亡。也许克里斯汀在他洗澡时让他无人看管，他要么溺水了，要么触电了。由于害怕后果，她可能伪造了一起犯罪来转移人们对她的注意力。或者，她可能在浴缸里故意淹死了他，然后把他的尸体扔进瓦洛涅河，把罪名嫁祸给“乌鸦”。这两种理论的问题都在于时间。
Christine had picked Gregory up from his nanny's house just after 5pm. Neighbours had then seen Christine desperately looking for her son just after 5.30. If Gregory had died in Christine's care, it meant she had just under half an hour to get him redressed and clean the bathroom for any traces of accident or foul play. She'd then have to get his body to the car without her neighbours seeing, before making the 12km round trip from La Pange to Doselle. Somewhere in all this, she had to write and post a letter claiming the crime and find time to call Michel Villemin and take responsibility for the murder. All without being seen. Nobody had seen Christine or her black Renault on the road leading from La Pange to Doselle.
克里斯汀在下午5点刚过从保姆家接走了格雷戈里。邻居们随后在5点30分刚过看到克里斯汀在绝望地寻找她的儿子。如果格雷戈里是在克里斯汀的照看下死亡的，这意味着她只有不到半小时的时间给他重新穿好衣服，并清理浴室中任何意外或谋杀的痕迹。然后，她必须在不被邻居看到的情况下把他的尸体弄到车上，然后再进行从拉帕涅到多塞勒的12公里往返行程。在这期间的某个时候，她还得写信并寄出信件声称对犯罪负责，并找到时间给米歇尔·维尔曼打电话承担谋杀责任。所有这些都不能被人看到。没有人看到克里斯汀或她的黑色雷诺车行驶在从拉帕涅到多塞勒的路上。
Although, one of Christine's neighbours recalled they were walking towards the Villemans' home at around 5pm on October 16. Christine drove past, giving them a small wave. By the time the neighbour reached the Villemans' house, Christine's Renault wasn't in the carport. The Vallone River contained unique microorganisms, but the water found in Gregory's lungs during his autopsy hadn't been tested. Therefore, there was no way of confirming whether he had been drowned in the river or elsewhere. whether he had been drowned in the river or elsewhere. With the media and public still fixated on Gregory Villemarne's murder, it didn't take long for word to spread that Christine was now being considered a suspect.
虽然，克里斯汀的一位邻居回忆说，他们在10月16日下午5点左右正步行前往维尔曼家。克里斯汀开车经过，向他们挥了挥手。当邻居到达维尔曼家时，克里斯汀的雷诺车不在车棚里。瓦洛涅河含有独特的微生物，但在格雷戈里尸检时发现的肺部积水并没有经过检测。因此，无法确认他是在河里溺死的还是在其他地方溺死的。他是在河里溺死的还是在其他地方溺死的。随着媒体和公众仍然关注格雷戈里·维尔曼的谋杀案，没过多久，克里斯汀现在被视为嫌疑人的消息就传开了。
The possibility that the young boy had been killed by his mother was scandalous news. Newspapers and magazines didn't hold back with sensational headlines and articles geared towards Christine's guilt. They honed in on the possibility that Christine could have been the crow from the very beginning. The public were quick to jump on board. Within days, the same people who were sympathising with the grieving mother were now accusing her. Christine responded, Those who believe I'm guilty are mistaken. Why would I have done that? I no longer have a child. I don't have anything. Police began looking for any discrepancies in Christine's statements and exploring possible motives. But Christine's story about the afternoon in question had never changed.
这个小男孩可能被他母亲杀害的消息是令人震惊的新闻。报纸和杂志毫不掩饰地使用耸人听闻的标题和文章，指向克里斯汀的罪行。他们从一开始就聚焦于克里斯汀可能是“乌鸦”的可能性。公众很快就加入了这一行列。几天之内，那些曾经同情这位悲痛欲绝的母亲的人现在开始指责她。克里斯汀回应道：“那些认为我有罪的人是错误的。我为什么要那样做？我不再有孩子了。我一无所有。”警方开始寻找克里斯汀陈述中的任何差异，并探索可能的动机。但克里斯汀关于那个下午的说法从未改变。
They looked for evidence that Christine could have been cheating on Jean-Marie. What if Gregory wasn't Jean-Marie's child after all? Was it possible that Christine could have had an affair with Bernard Laroche? Could she have been working in cahoots with Bernard or another of Jean-Marie's relatives? But there was nothing to suggest she was anything but unwaveringly faithful. But there was nothing to suggest she was anything but unwaveringly faithful. Christine and Jean-Marie had remained by one another's sides throughout the entire ordeal, and the accusations against Christine didn't change that. They appeared in public holding hands and gave interviews strongly rejecting the possibility that Christine could have been involved in Gregory's death in any capacity.
他们寻找克里斯汀可能背叛让-马里的证据。如果格雷戈里根本不是让-马里的孩子呢？克里斯汀有可能与伯纳德·拉罗什有染吗？她可能与伯纳德或让-马里的其他亲戚勾结吗？但没有任何迹象表明她除了坚定不移地忠诚之外还有其他表现。但没有任何迹象表明她除了坚定不移地忠诚之外还有其他表现。在整个磨难过程中，克里斯汀和让-马里一直站在彼此身边，对克里斯汀的指控并没有改变这一点。他们公开手牵手出现，并接受采访，强烈否认克里斯汀可能以任何身份参与格雷戈里死亡的可能性。
Still consumed by grief at the loss of their son, the couple was advised that having another baby as soon as possible could help with the healing process. Christine soon found out she was pregnant. When news got out, outrage ensued. Some viewed her haste to have another baby as a sign that she wasn't affected by Gregory's death. Others thought Christine's pregnancy was a form of protection. If she was guilty of killing Gregory, her fragile state meant she might be spared from jail.
这对夫妇仍然沉浸在失去儿子的悲痛中，有人建议他们尽快再生一个孩子可能有助于治愈过程。克里斯汀很快发现自己怀孕了。当消息传出时，引发了愤怒。一些人认为她急于生另一个孩子是她没有受到格雷戈里死亡影响的迹象。另一些人认为克里斯汀的怀孕是一种保护形式。如果她犯了杀害格雷戈里的罪，她脆弱的状态意味着她可能会免于入狱。
Christine and Jean-Marie denied all the rumours and accusations. They publicly announced their desire to undergo a lie detector test. The request was sent to the French President. It was denied. In addition to having a new person of interest for Gregory's murder, the case against Bernard Laroche started falling apart. When the team of handwriting experts had examined the final letter sent by the Crow, the minutes of their meeting hadn't been recorded in compliance with the Code of Criminal Procedure. Therefore, their evidence about the impressions of Bernard LaRoche's initials were deemed
克里斯汀和让-马里否认了所有的谣言和指控。他们公开宣布希望接受测谎仪测试。请求被发送给法国总统。它被拒绝了。除了有了一个新的格雷戈里谋杀案相关人员外，针对伯纳德·拉罗什的案件也开始瓦解。当笔迹专家组检查“乌鸦”寄出的最后一封信时，他们的会议记录没有按照《刑事诉讼法》的规定进行记录。因此，他们关于伯纳德·拉罗什首字母压痕的证据被认为
invalid on a technicality. The letter had since been tested for fingerprints, but the wrong material had been used. Not only did this mean no fingerprints were detected, but the wrong material had been used. Not only did this mean no fingerprints were detected, but the impressions were no longer visible. Any possible evidence on the letter had been effectively destroyed. Speculation of a conspiracy theory started to take hold. There were allegations that the case's magistrate, Judge Jean-Michel Lambert, had been working closely with Bernard's defence team. Questions were raised as to why the evidence was so poorly handled. Why hadn't further forensic testing been ordered during Gregory's post-mortem?
因技术原因无效。此后，这封信被进行了指纹检测，但使用了错误的材料。这不仅意味着没有检测到指纹，而且使用了错误的材料。这不仅意味着没有检测到指纹，而且压痕也不再可见。信件上任何可能的证据都被有效地销毁了。关于阴谋论的猜测开始占据上风。有指控称，该案的法官让-米歇尔·兰伯特一直与伯纳德的辩护团队密切合作。人们质疑为什么证据处理得如此糟糕。为什么在格雷戈里的尸检过程中没有下令进行进一步的法医鉴定？
Was Judge Lambert simply trying to throw Christine under the bus just to deflect suspicion from Bernard? But as Bernard's lawyers pointed out, there were other questions too. Gregory's parents had described him as being wary of strangers. It therefore didn't make sense that he would have happily followed Bernard into his car without protest. The two barely knew each other. Conversely, had Gregory screamed or fought, surely his mother or neighbours would have heard something. Furthermore, there was no way that Bernard could have known that Gregory would have been playing outside unsupervised on the afternoon of the crime. Nothing could have guaranteed him that there would be no witnesses. The idea that he'd pre-emptively picked up Muriel Ball to help him pull off the kidnapping
兰伯特法官是否只是为了转移对伯纳德的怀疑而试图把克里斯汀推向风口浪尖？但正如伯纳德的律师所指出的，还有其他问题。格雷戈里的父母曾形容他对外人很警惕。因此，他会毫无抗拒地跟着伯纳德上车是不合理的。两人几乎互不相识。相反，如果格雷戈里尖叫或反抗，他的母亲或邻居肯定会听到什么。此外，伯纳德不可能知道格雷戈里在犯罪当天下午会在外面无人看管地玩耍。没有什么能保证他不会有目击者。他预先接走穆里尔·博尔来帮助他实施绑架的想法
was therefore implausible. It also made no sense that he would have kidnapped Gregory in the presence of his young son and sister-in-law. Additionally, Bernard had no prior criminal record, hadn't made any semblance of a confession, and most importantly, no legitimate reason to kill Gregory Villemin. By February 1985, three and a half months had passed since Gregory's murder. With the case against Bernard Laroche becoming increasingly unstable, Judge Lambert made a controversial decision. Bernard Laroche would be released from remand on judicial supervision. Bernard immediately returned to his house and work, with the journalists following him every step of the way.
因此是不可信的。他在他年幼的儿子和嫂子的在场下绑架格雷戈里也毫无意义。此外，伯纳德没有犯罪记录，没有做出任何形式的供述，最重要的是，没有杀害格雷戈里·维尔曼的合法理由。到1985年2月，格雷戈里被谋杀已经过去了三个半月。随着针对伯纳德·拉罗什的案件变得越来越不稳定，兰伯特法官做出了一个有争议的决定。伯纳德·拉罗什将被解除拘留，接受司法监督。伯纳德立即回到了他的家和工作中，记者们每一步都跟着他。
Meanwhile, headlines continued to circulate about Christine Villemans' possible involvement in her son's death. The pressure against the Villemans was mounting. In late March, Christine was interrogated for nine hours. Her story never changed. A newly appointed panel of handwriting experts was tasked with examining the letters from the Crow. While the first team believed the writing was a match for Bernard Laroche, the new panel concluded that Bernard's handwriting was mostly incompatible. The family member whose handwriting showed the most consistencies with the crow was deemed to be none other than Christine Villemain.
与此同时，关于克里斯汀·维尔曼可能参与她儿子死亡的头条新闻继续流传。针对维尔曼夫妇的压力越来越大。3月下旬，克里斯汀接受了九个小时的审讯。她的说法从未改变。一个新任命的笔迹专家小组负责检查“乌鸦”的信件。虽然第一个小组认为笔迹与伯纳德·拉罗什相符，但新小组得出的结论是，伯纳德的笔迹大多不兼容。笔迹与“乌鸦”最一致的家庭成员被认为是克里斯汀·维尔曼本人。
This finding was announced by the media before investigators had a chance to break the news to Christine and Jean-Marie. Now four months pregnant, the news had a profound impact on Christine. She started bleeding and had to be rushed to hospital. Investigators visited her at her bedside as hordes of journalists gathered outside. They revealed to Christine that her handwriting matched the crow at a probability of 80%. Christine commented, You can have me do as many dictations as you want and say it's a 100% match. It will not change my behaviour or the truth. The results did nothing to change Jean-Marie Villemin's mind, he told reporters.
这一发现是在调查人员有机会将消息告诉克里斯汀和让-马里之前由媒体宣布的。现在怀孕四个月的克里斯汀受到了这一消息的深刻影响。她开始出血，不得不被紧急送往医院。调查人员在她的床边拜访了她，而大批记者聚集在外面。他们向克里斯汀透露，她的笔迹与“乌鸦”的匹配概率为80%。克里斯汀评论道：“你可以让我做多少次听写，并说这是100%的匹配。这不会改变我的行为或真相。”结果并没有改变让-马里·维尔曼的想法，他告诉记者。
Between the experts and Bernard's word, I trust my wife. I trust my wife. But for the grieving father, it was all becoming too much. Not only had he lost his beloved son, he felt like the media and law enforcement were trying to turn him against his wife. The health of their unborn child was now in danger. For Jean-Marie, Bernard Laroche's guilt was obvious. He was convinced the police were involved in some kind of cover-up. Why was a guilty man walking free while his wife was being tortured with such cruel and unfounded accusations? On March 29, Jean-Marie visited Gregory's grave.
“在专家和伯纳德的话之间，我信任我的妻子。我信任我的妻子。”但对于这位悲痛的父亲来说，这一切都变得太多了。他不仅失去了心爱的儿子，还觉得媒体和执法部门试图让他反对他的妻子。他们未出生孩子的健康现在处于危险之中。对于让-马里来说，伯纳德·拉罗什的罪行是显而易见的。他确信警方参与了某种掩盖行为。为什么一个有罪的人可以逍遥法外，而他的妻子却受到如此残酷和毫无根据的指控的折磨？3月29日，让-马里拜访了格雷戈里的坟墓。
It had been five and a half months since Gregory's lifeless body had been pulled from the river. As his father knelt before Gregory's white headstone adorned with flowers, angel statues and a picture of Gregory's smiling face, Jean-Marie thought he heard the voice of his young son. Go ahead, Papa, it said. To be continued next week. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
距离格雷戈里毫无生气的尸体从河里被打捞出来已经过去了五个半月。当他的父亲跪在格雷戈里的白色墓碑前，墓碑上装饰着鲜花、天使雕像和格雷戈里微笑的照片时，让-马里以为他听到了他年幼儿子的声音。“去吧，爸爸，”它说。下周继续。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。